what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification Bell that way you're
gonna be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way and and leave
a comment about what topic we should
cover next time before I start I have a
couple announcements before we start the
show guys I forgot my women should have
vote t-shirt today I forgot it I should
have wore it again but if you guys want
a t-shirt to you know think about this
guys women we can't even pick a
boyfriend like look at look at the men
we pick when we're left to our own
devices it's like criminals drug dealers
entertainers you know this isn't this
isn't great so it's like if we can't
pick boyfriends and husbands how the
hell are we gonna pick the leader of the
Free World take away I think we need to
take away our rights so buy a t-shirt to
support the cause the link is in the
description
um also guys also guys
um we have a membership tier the fourth
membership tier lets you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month you
think you wanna you wanna know how to
blow up on YouTube a million subscribers
in a year I'll tell you how to do it
sign up for my fourth tier that's a
one-on-one call with me once a month
also guys if you sign up for the third
tier you get me to follow you on
Instagram and then you can ask me
questions that way second tier
um oh that's the uh our behind the
scenes Vlogs and members only videos you
get to see me freestyle rap yes yes I
know and first here you get to be a part
of the live chat tonight King how many
likes to open up the chat
a thousand five hundred okay a thousand
five hundred likes and we will open up
the chat tonight but otherwise guys if
you want to be a part of the Chat sign
up for our five dollar tier it's only
five dollars a month and you can help
support the channel also we are going to
read super chats tonight probably every
like 30 45 minutes on the show king
um how over what dollar amount are we
gonna read 25. okay so you have to
donate 25 in order for me to read your
Super Chat
Um this can be a compliment a roast it's
all right we'll take it you can roast me
compliment the cat you know whatever
shoot your shot with the ladies whatever
you want to do okay
um also guys we have two clips channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily also I
have a daily podcast now five days a
week where I cover this week's news
treachery debauchery and if you want to
see that that's uploaded
um daily if you have any topics you want
to submit follow my Instagram just
probably things thing one
and I think that's all of my
announcements so um today we have a
lovely panel we have a lot of a lot of
familiar faces I think pretty much
everyone's been on at least once yeah I
know I was a YouTuber new I think
um so to start we're gonna do name age
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then go
around and then we'll do second row okay
so name blue
um 25 from Manchester see what do I do
for a living
um well fun fact if that's fine then you
can tell us well yeah um fun fact
um
fun facts oh I've just had my teeth done
that's a fun fact
um but yeah what what I do for a living
is probably more interesting content
creation Property Management
um literally just signed ten houses on
the same street for rent to rent oh wow
yeah a landlords he's done
you know so well you got you new teeth
right yeah yeah
all right go ahead so my name is Sandra
Slay
um I'm 22
um and I'm a singer-songwriter that's
like my fun fact I think
um and I'd also do Beauty so I do like
makeup
um brows and stuff like that
um yeah and I'm single all right
hi my name's sakaina I am 28 years old
I'm in a relationship and fun fact about
me
I'm running out of fun facts um
um I would probably say yeah I'm just a
Showbiz journalist and a TV presenter
yeah and you're you're going I keep
seeing the clip of you and kit together
yeah I was like it's funny you guys are
here I just I was just seeing yes you
see you were even on Rolo's stream he
brought up your clip yeah
in the beginning he just brings up a
bunch but I was like oh my gosh he's
seen kid now I've had like a few
YouTubers that have tagged me because
they've started responding to my stuff
yeah so we'll see okay we're gonna do a
part three we'll do part three watch out
see you're you're actually um I like
watching you on these podcasts because
you have really different opinions but
you're open-minded so sometimes I can
kind of see like wheels turning with you
I feel like I've grown a lot since my
like first yeah no no but that's what I
like about you is you're um you're very
open-minded and like even if you're
wrong you don't have like an ego you
know yeah yeah even if you you know so
it is what it is with me what you see is
what you get love me you hate me oh go
ahead hello my name is yusra I'm 26
years old and I'm single a fun fact
about me let me think well I'm finishing
my master's degree in three weeks so
this is a fun fact I'm pretty happy
about it
it's interrogation
boss I am 26. fun fact
same old I was born in a Mercedes
okay oh yeah I remember this one
I think I forgot that one I didn't
mention it
cool my name is Jay Johnson
I'm 25 years old and I'm single
fun fact uh I've got a music studio in
East London where I do sessions with
artist rappers and singers
you had 20 000 people come to an event
I believe that was until father Square
yeah I just I I saw sometimes they give
me notes about people so I'm like wow
that's a lot 20K yeah what do you what
are you you saying amongst other things
yes I've been in music and sound for
about two decades wow that's awesome
thank you uh hello my name is kit I'm
29.
um fun fact about me I'm on about five
facts too
uh uh I'm a landlord so maybe we should
work together there we go no I like that
thank you yeah yeah she'll fill out
everything
uh Lee from Birmingham 30
um fun facts also won a podcast
talk about similar things to what you
talk about basically so yeah yeah they
came they came to our defense a couple
we reacted to them a couple months ago
yeah and you know I won't say names but
there was a certain disgruntled somebody
very mad they're very upset so you guys
were hilarious yeah let me try them we
try we're still trying to get you one as
well so you guys are so far I know if
you're in London I'd do it but I'm like
every time I'm like I'll try with
something what we're trying to work
something out yeah yeah
um
okay so today
um I wanted to present to you a thought
that I had
ways I'm always thinking you know and
I'm on Twitter and I saw this tweet okay
so can you bring up the last thing I
sent you
um and so I was thinking about modern
society and just how in modern society
we really um
we have this term a real man and so I
was thinking what is a real woman all
right and I saw this thing on Twitter
and I want to see if you guys agree or
you disagree
all right so it says what is a real
woman bring it up a virgin a married
wife and mother a widow a nun everything
else is either a man a child or a [__]
yeah so no I'm not I'm not trying to
shoot I just I saw it all right and so
so then this guy that he came up with
some more stuff and I just thought I
thought it was hilarious so he added
um so if you're married you have to have
sex with your husband at least once a
week right
um no killing pre-born kids yeah no
abortions shave your armpits uh because
you know we got the trend of the women
that are like no shaving we're like
we're not that's not a real woman right
um an adult female
um you you can actually stand living
with so doesn't make everyone's life
hell around her wears heels won't try to
use the court system to extract your
balls through your wallet
no no no
Adam's Apple
um two X chromosomes nice legs is a plus
all right automatic disqualification if
she believes in the wage Gap
um she has to have boobs
um won't steal your children from you
for unjust reasons all right wait go
back up I want to read the top
um it helps if she doesn't try to steal
your house
wow
um so I just want to see as a group do
we what do we agree with what do we
disagree with anyone can talk anyone you
know I mean go ahead after two X
chromosomes
I think that's the one I'm like yeah
nothing else you agree with is a real
because we have a real man right like a
real man takes care of his woman a real
man you know
um protects his woman you know like if
uh if you know kit was with with his
girlfriend right and then some other guy
tries to like beat her up and he does
nothing that would not be a real man
right but those are personality traits
like right now I'm just probably this
then more physical more mostly physical
well I mean it's what men look for and
what women look for right that's true a
little bit I just don't really
understand the Widow what's that all
about oh yeah that's good is it like oh
you can't remarry is that what he's
trying to say no no he's saying that
like um if you're not a virgin a married
wife mother a widow or a nun then you're
a man a child or a [__] but he's saying
like if a Widow's uh like like it
wouldn't really be nice to put the the
Widow in the horror category so that
like that right right that's not her
family so essentially it's like a woman
could be those four things and outside
of that yeah and how about single women
no no if you're not a virgin you could
be a virgin single one
the house swings wild perhaps if she
doesn't try to steal you have that as
well well yeah I mean a lot of women do
that I'm saying how he said it like even
that it's like an automatic red flag if
she does try and throw you out well yeah
but you don't know that going in I mean
at that point you're already screwed
yeah that is true yeah I just want to
know if we would you say we mostly agree
with this or you mostly disagree
absolutely okay what do you disagree
with I'm gonna Allah let her go and then
you can go I just feel like it's just
crazy I just find it it's crazy I'm just
reading these things I'm just like
um you're clearly triggered like
someone's definitely hurt you what's he
triggered about like boobs for example
like not every man for example wants a
woman that has boobs well he didn't say
big boobs
I mean they're cutting them off nowadays
so he's trying to clarify right because
we have like what is a woman what is a
man so he's just getting real specific
so that's that's okay right boobs yeah
okay okay as long as he didn't qualify
the size right yeah I mean I guess but
what else do you disagree with I don't
like the kill pre-born children okay she
can't a real woman gets abortion I don't
I feel like it's a choice I feel like it
shouldn't Define if a woman is real or
not okay so if a woman has 10 abortions
does that make her higher quality or
lower quality okay see there's one or
two and then there's ten I need to know
context like why okay I mean two I mean
you didn't learn from the first one I
mean that's not me
well I'm just thinking so like when we
hear real man that's like the highest
quality of man that's what I think of
like a real man or like the man that we
want so wouldn't they real women like
the women that men desire not get
abortions in general I mean because she
get an abortion it's well because she
doesn't want to have the kid I'd assume
but what if the man like you know um
would want her to get an abortion if
she's not his main chick I'm not talking
about the men though we're talking about
the wit and this is a funny any
phenomenon I see whenever I ask about
what's a real woman we got to bring it
on the men no no when I think when I
think of like the highest quality of
woman you know like women that I really
look up to it doesn't like she just
would never get an abortion like that's
just never like when I when I personally
maybe you have a different real woman
right 100 it's crazy because at first I
seen it and I was kind of like that's a
bit harsh but then I thought
is it though because when people are
judging men they are very specific in
what they want so it's like it's a
similar thing really certain height
certain amount of money yeah I think etc
etc but when it's done the other way
around for some reason it's like a
negative negative and when you think
about it every woman is born a thin
virgin
not
every guy he's born tall
successful straw like no but every woman
starts off on the list
maybe you know chubby babies like well
you know I get sorry every woman has the
option to eat less true I mean but not
every guy has the option to be six foot
five
unless he gets um some sort of surgery
well yeah I mean we could get bbls and
like come to the same thing but men are
getting uh height surgery it's a thing
now but do we when we look at that are
we like that's a real man no no no no
sorry so not reach out oh it's okay what
else do you disagree with
um
see before I say what I disagree with I
just want to say I kind of understand
what this man is is trying to get at
um he's being he's he's being very
stereotypical basically he's because not
every girl likes to wear heels like I'm
very tall I I cannot stand wearing heels
so if a man was to tell me look I want
you to wear heels I'll be like bye
um but I'm still very feminine so just
because I don't wear Hills you know it
doesn't mean I'm not feminine you still
dress nice yeah you know you've been on
like yeah so that's what I mean he's
being very like you know stereotypical
there um but the shaves armpits I just
feel like
could that be the bare minimum could we
offer that yeah but I also feel like
what's wrong if she if she just decided
that like maybe she didn't want to shave
that day or that week or you know
I mean I think it's like you know I
think maybe he'll give her a pass if
it's a day but if it's a regular thing
like if it's a regular problem
that's a really good question she's not
wearing heels because of a reason yeah
would you wear them if you show her
probably I think so yeah yeah so yeah
yeah yeah I think I would but again I
like to be comfortable and I can't
really walk in Hills that much so me too
yeah like I actually and when I do walk
in them I don't look that attractive
it's not a good look I don't think he
would fancy me if he saw me walking in
here so yeah but I kind of understand
what he's saying but I don't agree with
with just like for example the armpit
shave the armpit it's this idea that
women have to be hairless completely
hairless but it's like so what if men
dress homeless
what if they they just swear there's a
real man never like shave his you know
face never trim his beard that's a good
point never y'all don't have to shave
your face yeah
same maintenance yeah right
guys do it two three times a week maybe
they have pizza us and they there's
women with like beards and stuff right
but that's a rare exceptions
they can have beards then but everybody
else no I still think she should shave
it yeah
I mean like you can keep I just if you
get Lazer then it's done yeah yeah there
you go but what if it's not black like
black hair like dark hair because laser
doesn't really work on really light hair
well let's let's try to avoid the
example
as a rule can we say we should shave our
armpits as real women I think let's get
rid of high heels all right all right
let's get rid of that one yeah we should
be able to wear flip-flops
I like my ballet flaps yeah
um so anything else is that it anyone
else I think what's interesting is
obviously whenever we use the term real
man all the things that are listed is
like a preference for the type of man
yeah a woman wants so if we're using it
in the same metric then yeah you're
saying this is a real woman as in this
is the preference of what maybe guys
would want then it's kind of a valid
point yeah and the the having sex with a
husband once a week A lot of people are
in sexless marriages so the women in
sexless marriages not real women yes
[Laughter]
no I think once a week's a bare minimum
but I don't think if they're not having
a lot of people are in open
relationships for that reason because
they don't want to okay yeah have sex so
if a guy's like okay I'm gonna do it or
whatever does is she not a real woman no
but he's he's saying that they actually
the bare minimum is that she should have
sex with him okay maybe we could say
offers husbands yes once a week at least
I actually don't think that's bad
because I looked at that and I went oh
Fair yeah right I was like and the
pre-born and first people that have
abortions that go through
grape essay and stuff like that they're
also they're not virgins Plus have had
an abortion but does that make them not
a real woman because they've been abused
period outside of criminology yeah no
but it's very common really it's um
no what
it's
[Music]
yeah I feel like the abortion one is
about triggering common and kill people
and that's like miscarriage as well so I
just feel like that's very intriguing
are you not a real woman yeah I would
say the ideal is to not kill the kids
yeah but miscarriages they're not you
don't kill the child well that's you
don't beat your stomach up and go off
well I know that I don't I think they're
talking about abortion though I don't
think they're talking about not very
clear though I mean I think I think it
is when it says doesn't kill pre-born
children but what if a man wants you to
like because a lot of the time it's the
man that's like well I'm not ready so
okay then then I hear me out you're
probably not a virgin
married wife and mother you know because
I'd imagine if he's saying kill your kid
you're probably just before Oh God a lot
of married couples have abortions well a
lot of married couples still go for
abortions though well typically I found
that that's because the woman wants it
and not the man but the man agrees to it
right but that's why that's why that's
yeah that's why I don't think I did have
a choice because you didn't have to well
okay what if you're pregnant what does
he do once she's already pregnant if he
does the situation as a man no no once
she's already pregnant what does he do
so if he doesn't want her to get an
abortion can he do anything but then he
says
what do we do now well let's talk about
the women's Choice the woman has 20
choices but does every contraception
work because I know many people who have
got pregnant they're taking my sister's
got four three children all have been
all have happened so he's probably a
liar but how can you be a liar with a
coin yeah because I think that when
women have plan B no if you have a coil
fitted inside I need you to wait for me
to finish and then you can go so when
women when women have plan B right we we
have IUD that we can get we we have
worship weight we have abortion right we
have condoms but then she wouldn't be a
real woman wait wait till I finish all
right can you wait so we have we have
condoms we can use we have IUD we have
birth control we have plan B then we
have abortion then we have adoption
um like my mom had an unplanned
pregnancy she gave it up for adoption
because my mother's a real woman
and uh
anyways
um and so we have all these choices
we're the men they only have condom or
no condom and he can't consent to if
she's on birth control because wait wait
wait so because he can't consent to if
she's on birth control or not because a
lot of women lie about it so the only
woman person that has all the
information the percentage of women and
oh it's really common oh it's really
common
to that husband oh yeah I mean okay does
anyone know a guy that had a kid he
didn't want to have because she lied
well a happy couple
yeah women it's a really common thing
sorry the crazy thing is that even all
those things all those contraceptives
are in my opinion
they are like Last Resort the first
thing a woman should learn from a very
young age is how to track a cycle you
can only get pregnant five days in a
month how do you get but you've got to
have sex at least once a week so that
that's tricky an ovulation cycle can be
five to seven days and so it's just
estimates that's all it is that's true
even you can see you can do the whole
counting backwards and it's I've done
that I've tried yes
my point is most women don't even know
how to track yourself yeah no that's
true actually we should raise more
Awareness on that okay I just I just
think that if you don't track your cycle
use a condom get on birth control get on
Plan B
um then don't do abortion or adoption I
just got no sympathy it's a choice
that's a woman's Choice it's not the
man's choice
the man the man has sex or no sex pull
out or don't pull out but like out to
condom or no condom boy if his excuses
though I just wasn't thinking but you
guys didn't have that conversation or
like yeah well okay you have to set that
back as a woman yeah but who controls
sex yeah we pick who we have sex with so
so it's up to you to decide if that's a
guy you'd want to have a kid with and
even after all of that the com section
all of that stuff you could still be so
wonder if it was to go wrong or if and
if it was to fail at least there's still
a decent candidate yeah that's very true
so after all of that you still kind of
have a choice like you don't have to set
someone someone that you know is
definitely gonna leave you I can't even
say that's not true yeah that's true but
I still don't agree with that of course
you're going to be upset
no but I feel like it's not the real
woman kind of thing like I get it and
it's like a mistake for sure for a lot
of women but I feel like to Define that
because if you see that person someone
else like yourself could have a whole
different list and what is that I think
I think they're pretty similar really
that like personally but generally I'd
say what what men find attractive in
winning is quite do you think do you
think men prefer women that have
abortions or would prefer a woman that
didn't have an abortion from my
experience I feel like people have told
me that they the goal is usually the one
that's causing issues trying to keep the
baby and they want someone that's just
so so I'm saying a guy that wants a wife
right and he's gonna look and and
there's one chick a who's had two
abortions in the past and chick B who's
have zero abortions in the past who will
he pick
the guys that never get married it
doesn't that's not what we're talking
about though yeah specification now what
if he's not look what if that's not
really well a lot of men won't get
married I would predict so what about
now I'm talking about the abortion thing
what if they're not thinking about that
no I'm saying no I'm saying if he's this
is a normal guy that wants to get
married and have kids and he has two
choices one had abortions one didn't who
would he pick
so I have a question for the ladies why
as women is it so hard for us to rate
each other
because people are just jealous I feel
like no I mean like why is it that
whenever we talk about better women and
worse women there's such a visceral
reaction
like when we could talk about there's
better men and there's worse men and
like we could all generally agree but
like when I say these women are bad like
virgins are better than non-virgins it's
like oh that's terrible because I
believe that the metrics are different
when it comes to men it's only about
achievement
when it comes to women it's kind of
physical features or something that
women are not involved with primarily
but then I understand that with like for
example low body count or no abortion
but sometimes it's just like how the
woman is born it's not something that
she can uh really
um I mean as I said I think I think a
big part of that is because women are
predisposed to want to be socially
accepted but more so than men yeah right
whereas men like we're not that we don't
want to be socially accepted but we care
about we prioritize other things whereas
women do want to be socially accepted so
they don't want to say anything publicly
their actual opinion right because if
other people agree with it especially if
it's other women right and they work
because women use their social
connections and stuff to kind of keep
themselves safe and to integrate and
stuff like that so that's a big part why
they would rather lie publicly because
they're socially accepted as opposed to
say what they really believe if it risks
that more men compete the guy always
wants to be the best guy in the room
girls don't want to be the best no no I
didn't say I didn't say I didn't say
that again I'm not saying we don't but
also women compete more definitely the
man always wants to be the top guy
that's why a lot more men will stunt on
social yeah they haven't got yeah but
you're proven my point because men want
to compete right they understand that to
compete you have to you being socially
accepted cannot be a priority yeah
exactly but if you want to be socially
accepted right you competing against
against other people you're less likely
to do that because against men for what
reason if you're if you're trying to be
successful to get a woman and marry like
why do you actually care what other men
think
because resources are limited
what you mean like yeah she does the
resources are limited like every you
know check you want another guy wants it
every woman you want another guy wants
it if you win it's because you were more
competitive and you were better so men
are trying to take other men's females
well she's going to end up with
typically she's going to end up with one
guy whoever that guy is depends on his
level of competition would you marry
someone that you took off your friend
well I mean I mean I know guys
that's not relevant to what I'm saying
what I'm saying is let's say she's a
virgin
first guy she sleeps with who's that
going to be he's got people compete for
virgins how many virgins even exist
anymore it's like well I mean there are
a lot of men in this room yeah but I
mean no yeah but if you let me finish my
point what I'm saying is well firstly a
lot of guys actually do compete for
virgins but really and truly the point
I'm trying to make existed exactly but
resources are limited that's the thing
they don't go back a hundred years ago
maybe they did compete for virgins they
actually hold on guys but I'm Gonna Let
You Go ahead finish your point go ahead
yeah I mean all I'm saying is resources
are limited which means you must be
competitive why is a woman going to go
with man a over man B there must be a
reason there must be a criteria
otherwise what's the point the criteria
is he has more resources even with that
example you used I would argue that if
if say like a guy steals a girl off
another
guy
um they won't they won't if the other
person finds out he doesn't really care
what the guy thinks whereas the other
way around where the woman fights would
you be trying to steal someone's girl if
you know what I'm saying I'm saying if
the woman finds out that he had a
girlfriend most of the time I look like
a lot of the time they will tell double
girl because they don't want the other
girl yeah I think that she's like a hoe
or whatever but then that guy is a hoe
if she's not someone and then she look
at the point yeah the guy wouldn't care
I wouldn't doubt the other maybe not
you're not wasting your time because
there's a lot of single females out
there so why do you need to piss about
trying to take in your mind that's not
the point though that is the point my
point is that he doesn't care sorry
sorry the thing is women are actually
going back to you know the fact that
like women are actually more scared of
what other women have to say about them
we are judged harshly by our own like
gender and I think that actually matters
more to us than what a man thinks and
who calls who calls women [__] more
men or women women yeah exactly it's I
disgusting how women speak about other
women
um yeah I think more women I think
that's why we don't want to be like you
said we don't want to be so open about
things yeah because we just don't want
the other girl to call us a [__] or
something like you know so would you be
more concerned about a girl knowing your
body count over a boy
and and it's always like competing with
like oh if a girl has the best sky like
if you know if she's got a boyfriend
who's got a lot of money that's such a
big thing for women like they will
literally hate on you for that it's such
a big thing because it's very shallow
that's how we prove like I'm talking
about good and bad results and even
women look at men like like they're in a
relationship and let's just say let's
just say quote unquote yeah the woman is
less good looking than the man yeah
right yeah the women's onto like
literally slagging off the girls saying
you're doing your dish or dish or this
like just because the man chose someone
has deemed less attractive exactly but
you don't know whether that woman has
qualities of that he's looking for but a
girl would or a woman would they're not
really women they're just girls like
they just go for that and they will go
for that guy if they see like you are a
very successful Pretty Woman you've got
it you know you've got so much going for
you and you're with that guy they're
gonna be like if she's with that guy
then that guy's got something very
valuable and I need to get that it could
stay in a
relationships this is how women think I
don't agree with it but unfortunately
women to be happy because you're
fighting over girls man like what the
[__] and that's why it's so hard to have
real friends girlfriends what natural
reason is it's just females have already
made that mistake and they don't into
that category so it's hard for them to
speak about it yeah they simply can't
refer to their own experience they've
already made that mistake but that
comment that you all agreed on was mad
like you said that if you say can you
just repeat it yeah yeah if you're if
you see a girl with a guy and they're
happy or he's successful You're Gonna
Hate on that one yeah
that is real life so when your friends
are happy and get married you hate them
yeah women do that all the time
but we're not we're not talking about
what's right and wrong we're talking
about what is and they will and they
will do something to they will actually
go out their way to sabotage your
marriage are you kidding me it may not
be I sit in the room we're just gonna
sit and agree with it as women rather
than stand up and say stop doing that
because no no no no no no we agree with
it but we want it to stop like we do not
condone it when we don't want to be part
of it but we're just saying that this is
our reality as women we tear each other
down
ever ever call me for being with they
would be happy I'd be if one of my
friends got married to a millionaire
tomorrow I'd be like yes girl and my
never gonna sit here right so then most
of the females don't think that then if
all of you are saying that you'd be
happy for you a friend to Marry a
Millionaire then that's wrong then isn't
it female stuff
we don't listen to what women say we
watch what we do and there's Trends and
there's patterns this is what we see on
a day today at the end it's a thing you
know your mum will warn you about it you
know your big sister will give you
advice on your friends I don't believe
it into the sea as well yeah I pointed
it out a few times and then eventually
they'll actually see it and be like um
yeah
but but maybe it's true men are so good
at spotting it as well like a guy will
always spot like that girl is that way
yep so we'll find it they're really good
at spotting that and mine will be
unattractive just to point out um
because I notice you're just you're just
basically trying to combat everyone you
realize that you can actually look at
the world outside of yourself and
outside of your friends yeah but um all
of these girls have said that then said
that they wouldn't hate their friends
for it so the majority in this room
if only everyone was like us the
conversation we're having is not about
anyone specific it's not personal to
anyone seated here it's just an
observation you can observe the world as
an observer you don't have to have
experienced something to see that things
actually happen Okay so sorry to say
something that women are all competing
for the same man depending on what you
want no they're competing for this but
if it's not the one the same pool of men
at the end yeah that's why this hatred
is yes yes all right guys so I kind of
wanted to go back to something we were
talking about earlier I wanted to go
back yeah so I wanted to talk about
virginity all right yeah yeah okay so
there's research that's come out that
says the more the poor Partners a woman
has the more likely she will be
unhappily married so now I'd like to say
their their data conflicts a little bit
by 10 to 15 percent so people always
come at me but we're just gonna go with
a couple of the studies and they're all
similar so a woman that's a virgin on
her wedding night
70 to 80 percent chance she's happy in
10 years now typically
um a woman when she has about five to
seven Partners
um becomes the the number goes way down
it's like 20 to 30 percent so you know
now
percent
unhappy
okay so we know that oh wait I gotta put
virgin
poor
so we got the virgins and the horse now
what I realized was female promiscuity
really leads to every problem in society
now what do I mean by that when you look
at um female so when a woman's unhappy
in a relationship what does she do
she will leave your ass
women we don't stick through it through
thick and thin
sometimes
no well only oh the horrors only do 20
of the time you know so so now so
there's a 50 divorce rate and the
general
um consensus of our generation is that
our we a lot of us don't want to get
married because our parents were
unhappily married and you continually
hear the the notion that we don't want
to get married I saw my parents they
fought forever so let's say the people
that stayed married half were unhappy
that's a 75 failure rate okay however
when you marry a virgin that's a 75
percent
successful yeah yeah now what happens
when she leaves your ass now for the men
they
use everything
at least 50 oh God
okay so they lose they lose little Timmy
and they lose all their money and so
basically the woman
um she leaves your ass she takes the
kids she takes your money and now what
happens to Timmy
oh
what happens when there's a broken home
in society right now we have
generational curses yeah now now we have
um uh more homeless people yeah we have
um drug addicts are mostly from single
mother homes homeless people are mostly
from single mother homes criminals are
mostly from single mother homes when you
look at it [__] really start every
problem in society even The Men We
complain about they're usually from
single mother homes you're more likely
to be rapists or from single mother
homes and when you look at the data the
men that raise their kids it's not the
same men raise better kids so so going
off of this this whole thought process
right I think we could fix Society
through one thing if all the men got
together and said all these [__] are
for recreational use only we are only
going to marry virgins then the Next
Generation the younger women would look
and say oh [__] I don't want to end up
like these [__]
and then then right so they would they
would say then they might adapt and then
boom the next round of 22 year olds
could be the mothers they just leave all
the [__] they date a nice younger
woman and boom like if Brad Pitt wanted
a virgin he could probably get one
you know the the top men would have to
do it first right because women don't
care what average men want let's just be
honest
I think that's how it used to be though
that's why a lot of people used to be
married yeah
so essentially
um I wanted to pitch this to you guys
and see what you thought men should only
marry virgins and not have kids with
anybody else because even at two
partners like let's go but what is what
is a [__] and I was thinking about this
okay and I was thinking about how now in
modern times we call a [__] a girl that
slept with like more than 10 people but
I was thinking I'm like even 10 that's a
lot that's like this whole room
you see what I'm saying and like now
five is like the new virginity like when
I ask guys they're like under five that
sounds amazing and I was like that's
pretty bad as chicks we're doing
horrible so my thought my thought here
if marrying horse means leaving your ass
losing your money and the kids which
causes homeless people drug addicts
criminals and rapists then shouldn't men
just stop marrying [__] boom let me
know what you think so so the thing is I
I think everything I'm saying makes
sense but I think that's kind of already
happening the only difference is that
instead of her being a virgin it's
basically like you said that they're
marrying the women who have a low body
count low sexual history as opposed to
her being an actual virgin because all
the quote-unquote other women who maybe
maybe super promiscuous they're not
getting them are they marrying them or
are they wanting to marry them well I'll
tell you what your numbers are well the
high by men are married the women that
they want and also the women who were
competing for the high value men if
they're like super promiscuous or that
and he only sees her as like a side
thing they're never getting the ring and
that's kind of already happened because
that's why there's so many there's so
many women who are like where the frick
are the good men who actually want
Community yeah yeah they're like they're
like with your virginity
[Laughter]
all right so so now it goes from 70 to
80 at two partners there's actually
quite a big drop it's still well fifty
percent so it goes from 80 to 50 so
we're gonna go 50 and now I know these
might be off by like five percent but
it's it's close so it's 50 then it goes
down to I think like 35 at three
Partners so now even at three four it's
at one of these two you're more likely
to be unhappy than happy I have a
question yes go ahead how important as a
woman how important do you think sex is
for her happiness do you think it's
quite high or not I think when you're a
virgin every sex is the best sex you
ever had yeah but I'm saying I'm saying
in general though I'm saying indoor how
important do you think sex is for her
happiness
um I think for traditionally not that
important for modern chicks oh my God
it's so important so you think the less
sex or less Partners a woman has had the
less she cares about it contribute to
her happiness no I think the more sex a
woman has the more she compares to other
men and therefore whoever she marries
isn't the best guy she's had but but
this is why I asked the question because
if sex isn't that important for a
woman's happiness if love connections
right then it's kind of like why would
the sex impact I'll tell you I think
again I think it's not important for a
woman's happiness historically but we're
in unprecedented time and I see and I
see I see women all the time say that
it's like I mean come on what does
butterflies mean what is like issue
they're looking for but that's not bad
but here's the thing what does that mean
I don't even think it's but I'm saying I
don't think it's about sex I think it's
about the men that she's been involved
with because let me ask all the women in
this room how many of you know a woman
who like I left my boyfriend because his
sex wasn't good enough
I don't think that's I think that I
don't know but they might cheat on their
boyfriend because the sex isn't good
enough but I think they cheat because
they're without because they can cheat
with a higher value guy not because of
the sex and also they're cheating
because that guy is more alpha male yeah
that's what I'm saying because we're
going to go back we're going to go to
the next no don't look at me
do you think they're cheap with high
higher value men I'm sorry I've done
that before about your men yeah
they're happy life so if a successful
guy and they cheat with the pool boy no
no no that's not the yeah but the pool
board is quite masculine
there's the higher value based on
attraction and there's higher value
based on yeah she would just be happy
she wouldn't even know she would just be
happy with the nerd like he's like she
picked the the nerdy guy in class but it
pays for me for virgins aren't
delusional as in like you still see
everything that's going on so even
though you're a virgin doesn't mean that
you're not seeing what's happening in
the world or like picking and choosing
who you want as well so I feel like it
doesn't really why does you're less
likely to act on it because once you've
acted on it before once then you know
the seal is broken so to speak so why
don't you just do it again
it is broken I also think that when when
women are having sex with a lot of men
it almost gives the woman like this I
don't want to say power but I would say
it sort of gives this woman like a boost
of confidence because now she can sort
of go out there and get the guy because
you've got to think as women all we
really need to do is dress good give the
guy sex and that's it and then we can
get access to all these things right we
can get that screw so as a so the
woman's thinking when she's had sex with
all those parts she's kind of has all
that experience she can now go and find
like that high value man and like get
him whipped or you know what I mean
that's how women think because now she's
got a lot of numbers and it's like she's
been there she's got that experience
whereas a girl who maybe doesn't have
any experience she will actually stick
with that guy and she will because yeah
because he makes her feel safe and she's
maybe a little bit scared to try outside
so are you saying that they want they
think that men want a woman who does
have a lot of experience
some specific type of men so it depends
on the men that that type of woman is
looking for so we're going to talk about
the high value men or these famous
actors or celebrities we see in the
media all the time I don't think
Leonardo DiCaprio is sitting with the
Virgin right now let's be real right
yeah but it's also about what they want
them for no it's not necessarily anymore
long term yeah but we're talking about
trend of men just not getting married
yeah yeah and you're going to see those
topics absolutely but what we're talking
about is what that does to a woman when
she's had sex with loads of different
guys it gives her this kind of like I've
got experience I can now go fly to Miami
and be without that guy who's telling me
to come here or you know but that's the
worst possible belief system to hold
because that's not going to yield the
results
I know but that is what women think
because that's why they can now just go
get any guy they want because they're
like that's not an accomplishment though
that's a pretty way to put it out yeah
my dicks a woman takes the more
masculine she becomes
they should be I've mapped out a very
nice modern dating Market here so these
are this is the sex okay this is the sex
happening so these are the hottest
people and these are the ugliest people
okay so the problem we have is this guy
is [__] all the way down here
and then these women are like oh my God
why do I always like men that don't like
me back well it's because you're
shooting too high sweetheart
okay we have the second the second guy
right come on so then then it's like the
women are like oh my God I always just
love the [__] no you just like the
men that are out of your league yeah so
that's her right here she's saying I
love [__] I love bad guys yeah they
usually because again what what
incentive do these guys have to stop
sleeping with everybody they're all
there none like I mean come on what
about the girls that are like deemed to
be in that caliber or like that League
Of The Hive men oh okay so I'll tell you
what happens they typically have the
same results because they're still going
after the man horse they might they
might get the commitment in the end but
I mean look at what happened to Logan
Paul's girlfriend oh god what happened I
mean she was a top a top lady I mean
when when the top women are around all
these top men all the time that's tough
that's tough I mean it's hard for them
to not be [__] you know I just want to
say because you were saying that women
think that they should have experience
but I don't know about what other guys
think but I know that if I meet someone
and the girl's doing bits to in my head
I'm like yo you've slept with loads of
people yeah I'm not really on it too so
you're having the opposite effect you
think you need to do that we're thinking
wow yeah yeah that's what girls are
thinking they actually think the guy
might judge me or something like that
they're actually a lot of girls are
really uncomfortable to have that
conversation with guys like but if
you're not good I'm like wow that means
it means a lot of people that's a good
thing
or if she has been with a lot of people
she's just no no that's true but
obviously let's be honest if you've been
with a lot of men you probably don't
know
I don't believe this because if women
really were afraid of like not having
enough experience they wouldn't call
women [__] yeah yeah you know I mean
like we know that's a bad thing because
that's the first thing we call each
other yeah women are also afraid to be
super open with their girlfriends oh
what do you what does that have to do
with anything well like you said you
know they why would they what did you
say sorry
I swear it made a sense in my mind we
were you were saying that the women like
they um are like nervous because they
don't have enough experience for the men
and I'm saying if that was true we
wouldn't call each other [__] yeah
man can men leave women for others that
are more experienced yes
I'll explain this so so the women this
is what will happen Okay so the the
girls down here will say what this guy
totally left me for a [__] and the
truth of the matter is she was just
hotter than you yeah hot chicks get to
get away with stuff that the mid chicks
do not us women like okay men know that
if a rich guy is being a dick he gets to
get away with it why do we think we're
all created equal the hot chicks get to
do more I just think men and women but I
think men and women both just give such
mixed signals in my opinion no no you do
you because you said look you've just
said I'm saying you want that good
girl just basically said what you said
just now you the men actually are
thinking no she's too expensive but then
you're saying he's gone off with the hot
[__] okay
just to have sex
that's not what I said I said sometimes
the [__] get away no but she said
that's what we hear all this no no no I
say it women will always think of the
example of a [__] that got away with it
and typically the reason they got away
with it is because they're hotter
sometimes they get away with it but so
in general a pure a pure hot chick over
a [__] hot chick the man's taking the
pure hot okay so then why are men
complaining about purity and all this
stuff
because we're not gonna commitment
explain it to me because these men are
actually marrying these women that they
say they're not going to say because
they're probably like she's saying
because they're very very good looking
yeah because females walk away because
they can feel that you think as a female
you can't feel when your man's been out
sleeping with people because you can't
yeah
women don't care it depends
on you if women if women care then they
wouldn't keep sleeping with the top guys
but all the data because they don't want
a relationship either guys
don't care about getting married by this
top one percent but that's why I bring
back to the point that all women pretty
much on the dating Mark look at our
[__] because again according to the
data if you've slept with three men so
then they may need to just stay awake
yeah exactly they don't stay away
I actually agree with you I think men
need to take one route and just go down
that route and stop like saying okay
I say that man should treat the [__]
like [__] and treat The Virgins
the real virgins that want to wait till
they're married will wait till they're
married
and she's hot it's fine yeah we know
wait so so men will accept it sometimes
but it's the exception it's not the rule
okay my girls are having confusion
that's why from a guy's point of view
only four percent of women wait until
that's why you're starting to see the
trend that's why you're starting to see
the trend of men not getting into
long-term relationships
I actually agree with you now but you
know why you're listening
no no no but yeah
let me tell you why because if all you
if all if every single woman turn around
and said look unless you put a ring on
it I'm having sex with you tomorrow no
no we wouldn't if you can't you control
it
I have a solution for the next round of
women obviously all of us are done you
know what I mean like like yeah no I
mean look around but like the 20 the 20s
the 20s this is for the next genre half
of us are predicted to be single
childless like what what percent of the
women that come on the show are really
going to get married probably most not
but this isn't weight I mean this isn't
it
no guys this doesn't mean
this is the data this is they're they're
investing in things like cat food box
wine because we're all just kind of done
so I say you know let's talk about the
next generation of women because they're
the only ones that can like fix this
thing so I say if the next generation of
women said we're not gonna shoot too
high so we're gonna stop like obviously
Brad Pitt doesn't want me I'm average
okay when we stop looking and say let me
date all the athletes all the musicians
all that stuff and just said look I'm
gonna wait till I'm married for my looks
match so here here like you do the
Snapchat filter on yourself would you
date it if the answer is no you're
shooting too high sweetie so yeah and I
think that would solve a lot but the
answer the answer still is to wait for
the ring because then that will
automatically tell you what your level
is yes
doesn't propose to you then it's not
your level I propose to you and he's
still gonna sleep with the girls but
you're missing it if they don't sleep
with anybody
what he's trying to say right is that
women set the standard okay because as
men we pursue you right and we care
about sexual access right women set the
standard okay at the moment the standard
the standard isn't a ring it's not even
commitment okay and he's saying for
every if the majority it doesn't have to
be everyone right if the majority of
women had the standard of if you're
going to be sexually intimate with me I
need a level of exclusivity and
commitment men would adapt to the market
this is men adapters in the market
because sexual access is so easy now
this is why a guy can go I'm gonna have
my Main Chick here and I'm going to
sleep with all these girls because
that's the market right now yeah because
we can't do you see what I'm saying no
because if you're treating a girl
is the reason women get typically get
cheated on is they shoot too high man
over here
oh so sorry
you know if because I'd say most men are
unable to cheat yeah I don't think yeah
you don't realize this because oh you
know you can just need to follow your
level
if all the women are looking up no one's
looking down this is what you're not men
do because you're calling these girls
hoes
attention to my diagram
how do you know if someone's equal equal
to you I'm on about them
commitment all right so what is the
solution here for people the solution
here
yeah
the solution here is that for women not
to sleep with anyone and then guys need
to actually pick what they want instead
of saying oh women
Not all men are the same a man still
being married for one because
most guys can't
do you want sex apart from the fact that
it's pleasurable and stuff okay you want
it because you get validation from it
but if you are with a girl that you
really like why do you need values
[Music]
is it from Instagram why do women need
validation with a million wait let me
ask all the ladies in a real question
right have you in have you gotten
attention from guys you had no interest
in yes or no yeah
because it is
happening do we know that hold on do we
know that some girls enjoy attention
even from men that they're not
interested in yes or no yeah right yeah
so we know this right so if we know
right that women can enjoy attention
from men that they're not interested in
right for men replace attention with sex
yes men can enjoy sex sorry having
sexual intimacy with someone
it's not different for men
no because there is a thing called
self-control are you just came no no
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that you don't need to control
yourself what I'm saying is I understand
it's difficult to understand because
you're looking at it through a female
lens but what I'm trying to articulate
to you is that the same way that it can
feel good to get attention because it
gives you validation right the same way
it can get feel good to get attention
from guys
wait wait wait wait wait
stop wait wait Jesus wait okay I would
take these complaints seriously if all
the women the wives if I could tell the
difference between wives and mothers and
single women I would take these
complaints seriously but I'm sorry most
women have open Instagrams most women
dress provocatively you cannot tell the
difference between a wife and a mother
and a single chick nowadays
and I'm telling you I know this better
than anybody because I have interviewed
hundreds of women on the show and I am
telling them no and I it's not a certain
type when it's 600 700 108 I've talked
to more people than everybody in this
room and I can't tell who the women on
the couch that come in that have
children and the ones that don't they
look exactly the same
time it used to be a time where wives
and mothers looked different than the
single chick because their men were
loyal at that time
you got you guys aren't listening
because the only reason that met you
that you have men that aren't Loyals
because you're you're shooting too high
there's a man on your level that will be
faithful to you
you just don't want you just don't want
the guy who's going to be fat and that's
the truth
knowledge on you guys there's something
that a lot of people have feel to point
out we keep talking about sex as if sex
is what men used to pick wives sex isn't
what men used to pick wives the one
thing men used to pick wives is
something I know most of you men on this
couch cannot give to a man which is
submission
oh to be submissive to a man I will be
submissive to the right man
if you're saying that women can't tell
um who's successful and who isn't has
any of you like dated a homeless man
yeah but guys
you've got to say the Homeless girl
homeless person people
's the guys I want to ask the guys
would you guys wife a chick that was
making minimum wage yep but she was a 22
year old virgin that would be ideal
difference
I want to go on this I want to go with
this what do women bring to the table in
um do we 2023 because what kind of women
we're talking about I don't know the
average woman even good women in 2023 do
they bring Purity are they virgins yes
or no
okay wait we're just gonna do yes or no
okay okay do have they typically slept
around or not slept around I would say
yes okay do they bring youth the average
age of first marriage is 31 do they
bring youth fertility
well if it's yeah you want then no no
okay okay so the average that's because
the whole system is messed up wait wait
no the average woman the average woman
has one point like four children does
the average woman bring children
200 years ago a guy could get a wife and
get seven kids out of it but who wants
now he gets 1.4 why do we yeah because
women are waiting so long and then we
lose our energy now well it's because
women again we shoot so long
okay but this is wrong because we're
telling
setup or whatever we get how is that
right now we're not saying settle I'm
saying get what you deserve and if you
can't get away
does she deserve a homeless man no no
you've seen that I thought I don't know
where you're getting this I'll give you
an example your your TV presenter right
like that's why you said that earlier
okay yeah so there is a girl that has a
similar job to you she was um 39 and she
went viral this year saying she wouldn't
date a bus driver okay so a woman has a
job talking into a microphone and I do
this right I I don't think I'm better
than a guy with an average job and she
was snickering at the thought at 39
years old of dating a bus driver is it
really settling dating a bus driver when
he marries her he probably doesn't get
kids out of it but he could marry a 22
year old jobless chick and have a whole
family so who's settling for him and
this is the problem what it's personal
it's her oh it's her choice it's her
choice it's depending on the lifestyle
you have to think women go after a
lifestyle because that was how it was
centuries back we would pick the
eligible bachelor who could give us
security but they always say slower too
many women they had no they had lower
standards of living yes
no no no I disagree no back then
this is this is how you guys spread
propaganda that's very wrong the people
the women that went after high-class men
typically came from high-class families
or they were very beautiful
that was those were the kind of women
that got high-classmen the rest had to
settle for the average Joe down the
street and had to work on farms with
their husbands and build themselves to
get into that upper class and I would
argue it's not it's not your choice for
commitment it's your choice for sex but
not for commitment yes it's the guy's
choice you have to convince him to
commit to you you don't have to say yes
we tell we show our hand based on our
language and even the worst even the
word that she shouldn't have to settle
when most women are overweight most
women aren't virgins and most women that
get married are old the idea that we're
settling for the guys when really the
guys are settling for us because in 2023
modern women offer less than ever before
yes
you as a person and you have to say well
what am I bringing to the table and then
you can decide women have all these jobs
that are pretty useless it's either like
no offense but like talking into a
microphone that doesn't build Society
I'm actually a journalist assistant
journalism doesn't build society and
make it run it's nice it actually
exposes a lot of the corruption in this
world and a lot of things that you guys
don't know about okay we don't care like
if if it wasn't for journalists you guys
wouldn't even be aware we don't care now
and women have these HR jobs they have
the all these jobs in society that
really we pushed this in the first well
again this is one this is why I don't
think women should vote don't men
but the problem is the problem is when
women get more choice we choose poorly
we just don't make good choices because
in the last hundred years we've had the
choice to be anything we've all chosen
to be we cannot compared
if we just to just go right you know
what I want the soft life okay but then
if someone's trying to kill it
their career it's lazy it's useless okay
I'll do why the soft life is lazy I
actually agree with
the Graham they'll see something about
like homemaking and be like wow I really
just want to be a homemaker and live on
a farm what do we do what do we do can
you listen for two seconds I want to
hear it okay so like look at a look at a
video of a day in the life of like an
Amish chick those women like this is
what they used to do 100 200 years ago
wasn't just sitting at home doing
nothing you served the men that was so
you're saying women should have good
jobs no because men say it and say they
don't care what the woman does as long
as you can make a sandwich
guys okay listen I asked guys this on a
first date if a girl said I don't know
much but I'll do whatever you say oh no
please yes
that's my point see what you just said
there no no no you see what you just
said yeah that's that is what you like
say to each other we don't say that you
say it's you say that you say oh you're
a doormat for serving your husband we
don't say that yeah other women sabotage
your relationship well you're not just
saying that like yeah for in five
minutes that other women will try and
sabotage your relationship yeah yeah
then their standards then they're gonna
get women like that because they're
gonna be like oh my God you're amazing
I'll serve you but a girl that's got
something about herself she doesn't want
to be a [__] Dormer
standard it's about under some people
know what role they want to bring to
them you can play that role without
being like Oh I'll just do nothing
because then you're saying so which one
is it I actually want to point something
out about female nature whenever we have
something for ourselves we're very
selfish with it we're men if they build
something they want to share it with
women where for women we want it as a
backup plan
because the minute men leave
women are the ones leaving they leave 80
of the time why do they leave they leave
because they're stupid they're
incentivize too as well financially
there's also a massive Financial
incentive you know one of them no I'm
serious one of the first and I can't I
can't remember the exact phrase but
basically one of one of the top reasons
is
irreconcilable differences that's what
people put in court because they don't
want to sit and list their life stories
it's not because there isn't a big thing
they don't want to sit and say slept
with my sister this is the thing you
don't actually know what you're talking
about and it's really obvious because
women are incentivized to put as much in
court as possible so they can get more
room for their children because they're
usually the ones with the children
see this is why I know you don't know
what you're talking about so it's
basically the reason the way the law is
written it punishes men for doing the
right thing if a guy protects and
provides for his family which is what
he's supposed to do and what we
typically want fathers to do then he
doesn't get his kid because he didn't
spend as much time
and we look at the data and we look why
because when women got power we voted
for policies that discriminated against
men
treated like women have this emotional
way of thinking that they can impose
anything on them and they would agree
because if man took Society society
would be so much different and nobody
would be uh submissive and nobody would
agree on any set rule or I don't know
any so she's right then yeah yeah and
that's what you're saying you could be
convinced to do whatever you want it's
not women's fault it's the society's
fault it's not my Society
because
I'm concerned societies there are women
in society as well I'll explain it to
you so even like phrases that you guys
are even phrases you guys are saying
like on the show like there's stuff that
you guys have said that I know is
propaganda campaigns like that you guys
literally just repeat and women we just
literally repeat propaganda because in
the early 1900s what they did was they
developed propaganda and they realized
basically
um here is the sad story and if you
don't agree with this sad story you're
this something bad and then women do
what you want they either buy the
product they either vote for this
politician or they um what is it by the
product vote for the politician there's
like a third one but they basically
develop propaganda campaigns so what
they they basically use women as a tool
to control society and we're a source of
two tax incomes in a household rather
than just one yeah so if you think on
the broader Spectrum you would
understand why everything happens yeah
and even in the Adam and Eve like what
was Adam's you know favorite what was
Adam's like worst sin he listened to his
wife
and it just shows what happened and I
don't say this to be mean but I just
think like when women are inherent
Nature's chaos like for whatever reason
I don't know why but we just I got a
question though so you know how we were
talking back to the the topic imagine
you've got a girl that's like a woman
that's like nurturing she wants to bring
she's got a lot on to bring to the table
she's she's peaceful she wants to help
you she's submissive whatever whatever
but she slept with three people is that
now well okay I'll I'll give you no
that's a gym okay
I'll tell you what I would say in
Pearl's world I would say guys hold out
for the virgins but if you're not make
her work for it because women we want a
man we have to work for we don't like
the guys that just give commitment to us
freely that's why we change but so you
know what but that's the thing most
women don't want to improve they don't
want to be the things that men value and
they don't care what men do want to
conquer don't want easy things if you
give a man like commitment easily he
would look for us well you're not
interested but you're not giving him
commitment you're giving him access you
commitment is marriage and he has to get
down in one knee thinking you're in
charge of commitment you can't be single
Who convinced the man to get married is
the woman he has to convince that's the
point working through that's the whole
point yeah I hope he would want it
to the value that the man gives to the
woman
that the woman gives to him is the
sexual intimacy that's what that's what
that is it's not because if you go oh
I'm gonna commit to you but I'm not
gonna have sex with you guy's not going
to take that deal
um but if you go to a guy I'll have sex
with you but I won't commit to you there
you go because the value that a woman is
giving to a man is different commitment
and sex men would still go and look
outside just for the sake of Conquest
just for the sake no yeah
in terms of working for it I think it's
this isn't about men and women this is
human beings in general we value things
that we have to earn yeah that's it's
that simple you are on a constant but
but that goes out of something else you
wouldn't you are never satisfied with
what you have but how does a man show
his loyalty
mainly it's normally for commitment
right I'm not saying it's right that
people do that but a lot of men do do
that because what women value is
security for me I I have another one
different thing it's only black and
white yeah there's no gray area yeah see
women are not like that yeah but you
should be black you should be if you
just thought you know
what it meant out to be it's the same
thing and I'd say women telling times
more than we talk with each other
because women are not black and white
and we're never going to be friends you
don't know what men want we are not
white you know what you want like that
though but we know what you want what do
men want
good looking confident etc etc etc right
so we know and we work towards that to
get women okay what doesn't what do men
want we're telling you and you're
basically saying that would that's not
what we want yeah it's just crazy
because the reality is men typically
want sex from women right yeah and the
top men have figured out a way to game
the system and get sex from women yeah
without because they figured out what
women want exactly but the women refuse
to figure out what the men want to get
what they want they keep and they will
keep arguing with men women tell them
what they want it's just fun and what do
you want is it the the Purity because I
wrote it on there
yes
the Purity thing yeah this is my point I
literally said it and when I said it if
you notice none of them not even listen
to it went over their heads yeah it's
crazy well and it's funny if women cared
men wanted why aren't any virgins on
their wedding days we don't care
and the thing is the whole thing with
submission is you've got to be with a
man who you trust enough for you to let
yourself get to that because as a woman
we are constantly testing you to see if
you are worthy of your submission and
the problem that we face right now with
a lot of women is they're seeing that a
lot of men are not stepping up to the
plate there's not enough masculinity
nowadays unfortunately the men are just
acting fathers
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right I agree though the
women are still giving what men want
yeah and I agree with you guys they
should stop doing and that's what we
said absolutely
step up and become what they were before
and then we're not gonna have this issue
I wanna I wanna explain something to you
the men are
here here's the problem the men actually
are bringing more to the table than
women these days but the problem is
women have an inflated sense of ego
thinking we're more important and more
special than we are because we got these
these jobs that are pretty much more
beautiful than Dr yeah so wait wait so
so men 45 of men do a job that runs
society that means they drive the trucks
they drive the buses they build the
building so half of men have a job that
runs the infrastructure of society
that's an important job okay so there
there's provisioning right protection
the average guy is stronger than the
average woman the average woman is more
promiscuous than the average man the
average woman is fatter than the average
man the average woman is the same age so
she's not even younger than the average
guy
that gets married it's like 30 and 30 or
maybe it's a year so they have a year
right so it's like when it comes to what
we're bringing to the table most men
like most I would say are great
grandfathers if they saw the quality of
wives that men took today they would be
literally disgusted hopefully yeah but
the problem but the problem is we have
no idea because the media lies to us men
lie to us because they want to get laid
uh politicians lie to us because they
want to vote we want they want us to
vote for them and we get to 32 never
having heard the truth about what men
think our entire lives we go to a school
system that's completely run by women
and that's why a lot of men are really
feminine because they're in the school
system that shames masculinity and so
the whole system lies to us and it's not
until our looks start to fade where we
kind of get a dose of reality and start
to Humble ourselves why do you think a
lot of women around the 30th age you're
asking me yeah become born-again virgins
because it's when hits in that they
actually realize what men want and so
they try to stop presenting as that kind
of woman yeah I agree to get the man
because she's obviously feeling the
pressure because she's older Etc yeah
yeah I've got a slight defense for the
women though because of men do lie to
you a lot to get sex that is true yeah
yeah but that is true this is why it's
so important that you know when we're
having a conversation like this where
there's no
um no act to try and get sick
listen to what we're saying because this
is where you're going to hear the truth
yeah when you're on a day or in the club
where they're gonna men will say
anything to you to sleep with you so
listen now not when you had a few drinks
and in the club that's all I'm saying so
you can take it you know but most people
will just leave this room I'll do this
every week as well and I don't care and
the other thing is like I agree with
that hundred percent and the other thing
is I don't really believe in this
submission when you feel like it I just
think it means you're not submissive
yeah because I'm sorry the women that I
know that are that are super feminine
they they don't argue they just they
just follow but are you gonna trust
someone who is Unworthy of trust to lead
your life the thing is the thing is by
the thing is when you choose a man that
is you by default saying I trust this
man no I I of course I understand but if
a woman by default is submissive I mean
if anyone comes to me
no it's submissive to the man that you
are interested in but even
but here's the thing I want to have
confidence in him but here's the thing
sometimes sometimes he's not going to
lead well and that's the problem women
are expecting Perfection from men when
we're not perfect like sometimes he's
going to do it but he's gonna leave but
that's the one thing he really Prides
himself in that he's like he can lead so
why am I going to be like oh I'll let
you off do you know that's the one thing
you want me to get question is my
question is are you following perfectly
no it's not about being perfect but
leading is bare minimum all right all
right this is what I this is what this
is what I think of when there's an
employee boss relationship okay and I I
just use this because it's the one that
we're the most familiar with when you're
hired for a job are you arguing with
your boss all the time when he tells you
something
no you know and so typically if there's
an argument how would the Union's
respect typically when there's an
argument it's the employee's fault
because they shouldn't even be arguing
right they should just listen
right yes and so so that's what why
that's why I say when there's a
breakdown in a relationship typically
it's more on the women because they're
just not listening okay but you lose
respect for the person I will lose
respect for my boss but do you know how
good leaders are made
no enlighten me why leading you have to
learn how to be a good leader yeah if
you don't let him lead how is he going
to be a good leader so I'm a practice
run
yeah
we want the man who's ready today I have
a question
that's what we have a question I have a
question do you do you think you were
raised to be a good wife
do you think you're racist it depends on
your culture it depends I'm asking about
you
were you raised to be a wife I was yeah
okay um so you you have a cookbook
my family have always okay and you
listen
um no I chose completely different route
in my life okay okay so my point is
women that typically were raised to be
wives are married before 25 typically
okay listen if I was in Morocco no no
I'm sorry I know no no no typically well
okay
all right because this is the funny
thing you guys inherently are starting
to blame the culture instead of yourself
when it's like it's like every woman
that's single over 25 there's probably
something wrong with you and you should
probably figure it out I'm not saying
I'm different I'm not saying I'm special
but the the difference is when men are
in a situation they blame themselves
where women will blame the world
and so and so and so my I'm not I'm not
talking about I don't know what your
life is I don't know about you but what
do you blame yourself for for not being
married yeah it's mine what's your
reason I I read it this isn't it this
isn't a therapy session no I'm not just
asking the question um I'll get I'll
give you one example right um I really
was chasing Sports I was chasing a
industry that makes zero money would you
say your parents didn't raise you to be
a wife I would say there was things that
I could have done better yeah I would
say yeah and your parents didn't step in
um we're blaming parents now no no you
know
um I don't know what your point is like
I don't know you asked her if she was
raised to be a wife
so I'm just asking now and I'm saying
that is your own fault my whole point is
to be accountable I'm not blaming my
parents I'm blaming myself and just like
everything because because my my only
point to that is because she keeps
talking about the men not being able to
lead and maybe we should come in with
this
and I'm saying we we need to come into
with some humility because we are not
always perfect followers we're not
always perfect wives yet we we put all
this pressure on men to be perfect
leader okay see this is it all goes back
to the the thing of like men just kind
of don't want to be men and we have to
just let it goes
like no but but you're but I'm saying
the women aren't real women like if
we're gonna go based off of them
I need to know that I have a life jacket
on but I need to tell you this is why I
think men should just stop dealing with
us and just go to the 22 year olds and
only married
hold out for five years and wait for the
next round so they the the Next
Generation no no I said hold out because
like now like this is exhausting to a
guy to convince you that he's he's man
enough to lead you and I'm not talking
about you personally but just in general
this is exhausting it's exhausting and
this is the funny thing like
especially for the people that are
arguing for instance you you say you're
into real estate and you sell houses is
it every sale you make that you make a
book from is it everybody you speak to
that you're successful with but what
happens when you're successful
eventually you go through a couple of
losses you learn from them and then you
figure out how to move ahead that's what
a leader does a leader is not someone
that gets every single decision right a
leader is someone that can get something
wrong and still have the guts to sit
down and figure out yeah but you can't
like you what are you meant to do as a
female then just be submissive to every
single man and hope that one marriage
I'll give every single man but every
man's meant to be a leader you have to
think as women we have a lot more to
lose your man but once you pick them how
do you vet them without submitting are
you gonna even let me speak like how are
you even going to get the money if you
can't even let a man speak I don't I'm
not I don't want to be married okay then
look at the stats for me then just
listen or don't but you can't keep
cutting me off the point is when a man
is trying to get his way ahead in life
and he has a woman who is constantly
pointing out all the faults he can't
focus on what he has to do as a man so
one way or the other you're either going
to have to decide well you've said you
don't want to get married so I don't
even know why you're even pressed about
this whole situation
comes for people that wants to be
married the point is if you want to be
married you need to vet your man first
then when you pick that man you need to
trust in his leadership that is it's as
simple as if a man if a man wants you
right and he wants to be in a
relationship with you okay does he not
have to demonstrate that you will show
you does he not have to demonstrate
before you give him the title of husband
or boyfriend does he not have to
demonstrate that he would be a good
boyfriend yeah right she has to lead by
example right so why would you think
that if you find a man that you're
interested in and that you want to be
his girlfriend do you not think that you
have to demonstrate that you would be a
good girlfriend to him by showing what
he would what he would be if he
committed to you yeah I know but we're
talking about marriage here I know but
what I'm trying to say is before you a
lot of this the contention is why would
I submit to a man right if I can't trust
him right why should I trust him blindly
it's literally like me going on an
airplane and the pilot is not qualified
why would I do that okay to women it's a
higher risk we have a lot more time and
we look for safety remember we look for
safety but you bet who you go so we will
go and be with the guy you do vet who
you're going to flight with yeah because
that's why you choose Airlines you don't
choose random independent whatever off
the cuff right you choose Airlines
because you know that's part of the
vetting process the best yeah but like
do you ever go on an airline where you
think I wonder if this pilot is
qualified no no no I want to point
something out it's like you're repeating
propaganda because you're saying we have
more to lose have less to lose the men
have everything to lose okay you're
speaking financially no I'm talking
about everything even matters as well
yeah kids financially
finances
women if women cared about their fertile
years they'd get married when they're
young but we don't choose to well you
can have IVF at like how old
is that mentality it fails the most most
of the time and this is the problem
women will blame the men for not wanting
to get married instead of trying to
improve the problem should we check a
men's sperm count before we marry them
make sure that they can give us all
these kids
man and then you're in Fertile should he
just divorce you because now you can't
give him children
I would say India I would say this is
why women the next [__] like they should
just throw us all away you know what I
mean they gotta just throw this this is
too much for them I feel for it so it's
like then just say for the next five
years we're marrying nobody and then the
next round to 21 22 year old virgins
they marry and there you go everything's
solved oh gosh
we would be we would be the victims of
our own decisions but the thing is when
a man commits a crime and goes to jail
he doesn't blame the world he
understands it was his own choice
whatever then a man comes out and is
reborn and everyone wants to treat him
like a brand new man
how many minutes
and then you can go and get a Jason yeah
we need to go one at a time what man do
you know right that's come out of prison
and the world is treating him better
we're not saying the world but like a
man will want to be treated like he
hasn't done that but he's done his time
and that he should be allowed now to be
a valuable man but reality
is that he doesn't get that yeah yeah
but they want that yeah but we're saying
like Okay but women of a certain you
know if they're promises where want a
certain man to commit to them but
they're just not getting it and then if
they do get a man who would commit to
them they say that they're settling but
you don't you don't see the drug dealers
coming out and say your drug dealer
shaming but the women will come out and
say you're a horse
and [__] shaming
but love drug dealers
think yeah that women are good support
mechanisms
what do you mean exercise a little bit
do you think like in a relationship do
you think there should be in the
supporting role or the leading role like
what women should be in the support
personally I think supporting role so
you think that women are good supporters
absolutely they shouldn't be so if he's
not a good leader in it ain't you part
of the problem then because you're the
support enroll in it you could you could
have it
I mean
team effort I mean but I feel like you
see how no one said anything when I said
something positive about Lily no no no
no I wanted a joke by themselves
but I'm just trying to think as me like
I'm 22 so you guys still think I got
some I still got some chances in me but
like like I'm 22 and I'm not the real
woman do I mean like I'm not like I've
been through wherever I've been through
but it's like now the problem is not to
take like what it's not about me saying
I'm not a real woman it's me taking
accountability saying okay maybe I'm
didn't do whatever how do I then is it
just like we he said joked around is it
done now okay
yeah
nobody ever asks to this they don't care
okay I'll tell you I'll tell you the
number one this is just you know from
the guys what they say the number one
thing a personal trainer that's the
number one dating advice for women get
in the best shape because then you can
get away with more weren't raised to be
a wife if you're hot enough they might
Overlook it okay that's step one uh you
got to get their attention right step
two you gotta find the married women
that actually are submissive to their
husbands and learn from them I'm not
saying go to me right but it's like go
find the women that have married are
married stay married and their husbands
actually like them and can vouch for
them because a lot of married women
their husbands are miserable so you
gotta find the ones
um yeah and then I would say those are
the first two steps
oh yeah yeah then she's kind of what do
you mean if she has kids she has
children already then she says I don't
have children yeah
if you have kids it's time to get back
with your baby daddy
[Music]
she was trying to solve all the world
the world problems they always come to
me and say pearl what are your Solutions
well today I got some
no it's you're wrong no no she's not
right
oh
oh lower your standards yeah
because I know what I bring to the table
even though even though I may not be
here can I ask you a question if you
what would you say to the guy who lives
in his mom's basement right is
overweight right isn't actually like
working on his purpose Snead thing and
he says I deserve
a girl like Beyonce and if he doesn't
get someone like him he's settling what
would you say to him
well first of all
no I'm just asking like what would you
say to him because he doesn't want to
settle you know what so what would you
say to him obviously like go like
Beyonce like so he wants so he goes I
want a girl I want a girl who is very
gorgeous who's very feminine who is very
submissive and is going to support me
and everything that I'm doing I do
believe that you should first look at
yourself before you try and get what no
but I'm asking you what if you guys if
he goes I'm if I take any girl that's
not that I'm settling what would you say
to him
as well because not every woman's here
with the Ronaldo yeah
here's the thing there's actually right
I believe there's actually there's
actually no there's actually no such
thing I don't know yeah
Ronaldo picked a normal girl working in
a shop so it's it's there's no such
thing to say because human beings right
we're selfish we're selfish by Design so
let me tell you what what
um Ronaldo's girlfriend has that most
women don't have one she's super
feminine so she's very oh yeah I think
she's beautiful she takes care of her
sheep three she's submissive I keep
saying that word but you guys it just
keeps going over your head Ronaldo is
the guy that is the top guy right he's
out there what do you actually hear
about his woman you don't hear anything
well that's amazing
well most women today want to be on the
same level with their mind they want to
be in the media they want to be in the
Limelight they want to be the one taking
the shine while their man is doing his
thing that is a problem it depends what
your career choice is though yeah but it
doesn't matter if you're happy and it
doesn't matter what you do like for
example if I want to be like a let's
just say an actress singer whatever
whatever that comes with being in the
Limelight if you that's what you want
yeah but a lot of guys a lot of guys
wait wait wait so I want to talk actress
and singer they don't typically make
good wives I mean let's look at the big
actresses and singers of Our Generation
Taylor Swift Selena Gomez they all end
up by themselves so it like success
comes at a cost unfortunately and in
fact that's a big that's a big process
as well I don't agree I don't know who
said it just now but someone said oh you
know the man doesn't want to be with
that girl who who's seen and stuff and I
used to think that like for so many
years because I would never find like a
guy who was like okay with my lifestyle
and things like that but I found someone
who loves what I do not only loves it he
celebrates it he's on the red carpet
taking photos of me celebrating what I
do and championing me so that is out
there and I don't think that makes you
any less of a give me my choice but I
still submit to my man well give I'm
saying give him my choice if you ask
said to him yeah right now I'll change
everything about my life here I'll stop
doing all of this now
no but I'm saying to you if you gave him
the choice what would he pick what do
you mean what would you rather but he's
weird
he doesn't have a choice
what do you think he would pick the
reason he loves it is because he loves
you yeah yeah because he doesn't have a
choice he didn't choose he didn't find
you more attractive because of your
career he because because he loves you
and cares about you he's like well if
this contributes to your happiness then
I love that yeah I love you that's what
yes but I just and that wasn't my point
my point was that like oh
oh man has to be at the top and the
woman has to just be submissive I'm
saying that look our Dynamic is
different yeah I'm at the top and he's
like they're supporting me and they're
with you try and still submissive
Dynamic is the same you just have
different careers is that your career
you're on the spotlight yeah but I'm
still submissive and that doesn't make
him any less of a man or anything I
won't say that I'm saying if you gave
him a choice what do you think he would
pick
well I don't know maybe
and to answer and to answer your
question were you it's basically women
if we want a certain type of guy we
neither either need to improve right we
need to get in the gym we need to learn
what what men want cook become become
more submissive learn from married women
or lower your standards and get what you
get you know I really I really I think
it's pretty there are some really
ugly guys that she and and okay so I
wanna I wanna I wanna I wanna break this
down for you because the problem is
women think that ugly guys like most
ugly ugly guys are just on their level
to be honest because women find 80
percent of men as ugly unattractive so
you only find two out of every 10 men
attractive so that that's the problem is
when you look at like what like what
women rate as attractive it just means
you're like shooting too high typically
I'm not you but like in general yeah but
also this is another thing like it's
clear women don't actually know what to
look for in men yeah because everything
we've said today have been all
superficial
ugly guys rich guys handsome guys it
doesn't affect their characteristics you
need to look at the character of a man
it doesn't matter what he looks like it
doesn't matter how much money he makes
if his character is flawed once his
character is flawed he can be the
richest guy on Earth he's still gonna
cheat on you so you need to look at the
character of a man then you look at his
bank account but then then you look how
do you find a character how do you see
the character in men that lie no don't
listen to what he says listen to what he
does questions look at what he does yeah
so first of all ideally if you're
looking for a man for anything serious
I'm not talking about if you want to
have sex if you're looking for a man for
everything anything serious first of all
you shouldn't be the one trying to vet a
man on your own but like that's the
worst thing you should do as a woman try
to vet the man you're going to take
serious because one you're most likely
going to be clouded by his lies or the
way he's gonna speak to you the romantic
date is going to take you on you need to
look either in your friend group or your
family and get other people to vet the
man for you that's that is the first
thing you should do never try to get the
money other men no yeah but this is your
standard practice back in the day it was
like your father would be the one yeah
right yeah because I mean I mean look at
look at who we pick when left to our own
devices every chick has a toxic
ex-boyfriend every chick has a boyfriend
that cheated on her and it's like we we
pick we're more likely to re reproduce
with literal criminals
the non-criminals or there's something
like that so it's like what happens when
we're left to our own devices it's not
good because we're just too emote like
we can't make us not women we're
emotionally led men are much more
logical so it's like my brother like
literally it's like if I if I bring him
a couple questions about he'll ask me a
couple questions and it's like yes no
and he's usually right yeah that's so
true yeah where where women it's like
well but well he might I'm not sure
so so you saying like a man will
definitely even if let's just say
they're not they're not willing to give
you a relationship they should imagine a
guy's telling you I want to give you
this imagine he buys you this and then
and it takes you to to or like be very
full and be like the perfect person that
you would say they should say the
actions actions imagine you do that now
you take that person and then this [__]
okay but think but the thing is
we all waited until we were married
like if his actions are representing
that he's taking you seriously right and
like because you when if you look at a
guy's actions you can tell if he's
taking you seriously or not like because
if you're just having sex and most of
the time you're hanging out it's just
Netflix and chill he's not taking you
seriously if he's not introduced to his
friends he's not taking your holiday all
of this stuff he's not taking you
seriously you know that right but the
thing is the issue is and this comes
back to the board women can use sex to
get access to guys that are actually out
of their league yeah and so what happens
is that it's so used to having sex with
guys that's what I'm saying that on in
their league right they acclimatized and
they think that's their standard and
then they go why are the guys who are my
standard not commit to me are all guys
are trashed none of them want to commit
but actually it's like
your standard isn't who you have sex
with your standard is who you get
commitment from right and that's
actually where you're standing because
the thing is the equipment for guys is
like I'm spending all this money and all
this attention on this girl but she
doesn't want to be sexually intimate
with me regardless dates I take her out
but like I have all her attention but I
don't have any of the intimacy because
bro you're using money to punch above
your weight that's why see what I'm
saying yeah no
I hear it I definitely I'm gonna I'm
gonna Read Super chats for a second
Super Chat um also guys if you do have a
question for the panel you I saw someone
asking if I would super I would ask it
um I will over 25 okay Lionheart Richard
how do you choose a guy to submit to
date with intent maintain your Chastity
and involve your dad brother uncle are
not sexually are that are not men that
are not sexually interested in you to
scan the man you want a courtship with
FS Claire Pearl bless you but there is
no saving Society just listen to how
these women react to the reality of life
it's over walk away fellas they are no
longer worth the risk Doug MPA thank you
King for thank you King for being for
producer for being the voice of reason
thank you for Pearl for being amazing
and having shows like this blue hair
tips is a demon she has the voice of a
demon and woman like her should be
avoided at all costs shoe um shoe Jam I
didn't even know you had blue hair
um I am 23 from the Midwest I'd love to
share my experience my background I'm a
farm mechanic working for a dealership I
bring in 50k a year I'm in the National
Guard I also have a volunteer paramedic
I've been cheated on and dumped because
of money and being too busy Alexander
1284. thank you for what you do fresh
and fit brought me here Steven Sutton um
men don't need validation from sex men
genuinely don't seek validation like
women do sex is important to men as
attention and validation is to women a
man Emmanuel Christ Ian I really wish
the girl on the right would let people
finish men don't only lose money in kids
men also lose their minds to depression
and commit self-deletion and delete
other people every woman can be
desirable if she manages what goes into
her body both food and Men Pearl you are
looking for uh
are you looking for Talent on Toronto
Canada
um no right now
I might do one or two more in Chicago
but right now we're going to sign
probably like one or two more people in
London out of this office and then
maybe one or two more in La I think
we're gonna I'm pretty sure we're gonna
do la
um London and then Chicago but my main
uh Focus right now is London so we're
probably gonna sign people in the next
like two weeks so if you are interested
in being a talent um make sure you DM me
and like DM me like what your show pitch
is and your Instagram whatever it is
basically what that means is I do
everything so I do the editing the
shooting basically everything you just
show up and talk but it is a full-time
thing so if you want to like just come
occasionally this is not for you okay uh
Mac perk hey Pearl this is for all the
women on the panel if body count doesn't
matter then why do women are women super
uncomfortable when asked about it 93
topai it's funny how men expect a stable
or it's funny how women expect a stable
man that provides and Etc but never too
oh this is from the last show okay let
me refresh this really cool in it yes so
yeah this is I like don't even really
get hot anymore because I'm just so used
to it it's
England's it's England's fault because
you guys don't have air conditioning I
don't understand
it it would be blowing so much in
America you would you would be like cold
but yeah I just never hardly ever need
it yeah yeah
um okay so what I wanted to do
was another whiteboard thing so again
you know I was we had the conversation
as women why can't we rate each other
right like what so what I wanted to do
oh no this is not what you think what I
wanted to do is offer grades like in
school we're gonna do a b c d f on the
Whiteboard all right is that how you
guys do you have the same grading system
yeah yeah
all right and we're gonna we're gonna
rate what is an a woman what is a B1
what is a c woman a d woman an e woman
and an F so
um I'm gonna go up there but think
amongst yourselves what what is an A1
can we um see like what the women think
an a woman is and what the guys think
that's so good that's like the best idea
I think it's interesting I think we
would probably all unanimous unanimously
agree when A1 man is oh yeah yeah
definitely I think everyone would know
to be like that's an A1 yeah but A1
woman I feel like it's going to be yeah
it might seem different it'd be
interesting to see them can't you say
just for something good for women in the
room right like kind of say what we're
saying that all the stuff here that
we're kind of talking about and saying
you know as in like you're getting this
guys who are telling you just the bear
truth most women have no idea and they
won't because most guys lie yeah yeah
you're still all young enough to be in a
in a position where you're not going to
get to 45 single and try this but I
really want the family and I don't know
why I [__] up but now realities hit me
just what I'm saying and I know like
like what is a real woman I think all of
that was preference do you know what I
mean like the same as what we say what a
real man is it's actually about a
preference of a Kind Of Man a woman
wants
um well this conversation like there's
value in this conversation even if you
disagree at least you're aware of a
different perspective because naturally
you start to look at things slightly
different with a different lens and then
you'll start to recognize patterns and
be like [__] that's what that is but I
think you have to become the preference
though
let's let's ladies amongst ourselves you
know girl code so
um what I want
um oh okay yeah sure um so King can you
pull up Google
um don't put it on the screen yet but
just get it ready so for the women I
want to talk about what does an a woman
look like
how hot do you have to be to get nay
let's start
give me an example of a celebrity
influencer that we can Google everyone
can see Adriana Lima all right let's
pull up Adriana Lima
and we're gonna we're gonna see if we
all agree that that would be an A or
I mean she was she they said that she's
her face is so proportioned and
everything so she's let's see deemed as
actually beautiful I mean I read this
but let's see all right
um how many bodies can an a woman have
an a to get an A this is like zero zero
one
zero one we'll give her minus five all
right what do we agree sorry so who says
zero was an a
all right who says one is an a raise
your hand
all right two bodies raise your hand two
all right I'm going back to zero
zero who says three bodies I also need
everyone in the room or just there no
the women first
so three are all right so who who would
we agree through your last raise your
hand if you say yes three or less
she says here I say zero I say virgin
yeah yeah but it's all right it's all
right she says three what do you say
two two all right two I say zero zero
all right so we'll do a con what do you
say how many
I I don't I don't wanna comment to be
honest I don't believe in greed and
women like that like you're literally is
do you believe in greeting men
if you had to choose someone I chose I'm
not answering the question you know what
compromise we'll give her one mistake
we'll give her one that's not yeah she's
fine
okay all right ladies is this would you
say I would say that's that she's pretty
hot yeah yeah would you guys agree she's
known as one of the most beautiful women
in the world you've all got nice eyes
okay what's her name all right uh
Adriana Lima she's a Victoria's Secret
supermodel yeah
yeah all right so Adriana Lima do a
couple pictures just to double yeah I
mean we're not saying this is the only a
woman this is just an example so but if
we can uh I would I would say yeah I'd
say she's younger like in her Victoria's
Secret model days yeah
yeah she's attractive yeah
um someone I would think of is um
what's her name
I cannot oh I'd say Margo Robbie but not
now not now I would say 10 years ago
Margo Ryan
no she's like 33. oh yeah she's so cute
but I'm just saying yeah she's cute
she's cute yeah like like that but to
Wolf of Wall Street Margo is just a
different level like yeah yeah yeah
she's whole yeah especially in that
movie well I think she's still filed but
yeah well I said an a I think I think
she's more of a b now you're like you
think she's an A minus wow I don't know
okay she's hot she's pretty good okay so
we got the looks level we we agree on
that anyone disagree
no okay what else um what else does she
need to have to get an A
um just women do it later a great buddy
great buddy like 10 10 body well that
kind of goes oh okay you know but like
what else outside of looks uh no
children
[Music]
um okay what else what else anyone
um it's submissive
yeah look at this think about it
she's like I studied yeah
would domesticated uh go in that one as
well no domesticate no because someone
could be submissive cooking and cleaning
okay how how can we measure the cooking
like what does she have to know
a real Chef would know the answer she
needs to be able to just like cook some
like good homemade food but like what
like nice meals like hearty meals like
what well it depends on the man what he
likes you know what's funny this is why
I know like women today can't cook
[Laughter]
and like crazy that's what I was about
to say women that can't cook say steak
dish my statement dish seafood pasta
like a creamy Cajun like Pro Lobster
linguine something like that I just love
my Seafood so yeah so I say I say she
has to be able to bake from scratch
ain't nobody got time for bacon nobody
does
no it's not that difficult anymore
but then hell not difficult to bake you
think I do debake I know how to do it
okay I'm gonna say she has to know how
to make
hmm
you know what she's an ace let's say
about 50 recipes from scratch oh God we
have heists the School of Excellence
shout out to Lewis house so funny you
can literally go on YouTube and learn
how to code but women don't can't even
go on YouTube and learn how to bake
that's crazy man
you know what yeah I would kind of like
round up the cooking bit just to say if
they know how to like kill the sick in
the kitchen then they know how to
because I know the basics of everything
else you know what heal the sick
so if you're sick don't know how to heal
you they can make ginger tea they can
make like you can know your carbs or
natural resources then they'll know how
to cook home remedies remedies she's
just been listening
absorbing it all in that's good bro
that's all her we didn't even touch them
remedies I was like oh [__] yeah yeah
okay anything else should we add today
um
oh no abortions
down
oh yeah yeah
according to that you can uh can you can
take down the girl
um
any so I I got one but I want to see if
anyone else thinks of it oh wait two
parent households sorry Mom and Dad two
parent household oh she can't leave
she can't leave it's crooked Now isn't
it
yeah loyal good one
I'm gonna add you know I think a guy if
he went home from work and got blow jobs
and massages every day he would be a
happy camper you know what I mean right
you know what she's gonna say something
outlandish because you start smiling
just before she said something she
starts laughing before she even says it
all right any anything else ladies
okay that's a queen which is a good I
think most I think the guys oh wait I'll
add one more I'm sorry go ahead go ahead
healthy healthy oh yeah no fatties
with everything like then they're not
sticky sticky they don't have any like
diseases she's not wrong yeah
we get it I'm I can't fit it but you
know okay
um all right if a girl has a kid how
many letters does she go down
B
C I don't really want to
dude
she's off the charts okay okay
I'm gonna personally say a kid puts you
down to a c or a d I'm my gut is telling
me d d yeah that's real sad oh it's
really sad who thinks that's General all
right all right so so I'm not thinking
it a and you have a kid are you down to
a b raise your hand I just you're down
to a c raise your hand
I see or a raise all right d raise your
hand
all right I say d three d's okay
sorry
I think it's gonna be easier
I think it's gonna be easier now we have
the ideal and we're gonna say like what
if everything brings you down to okay so
what how how much does being 20 pounds
overweight bring you down
from
and a goes down to uh with 20 pounds
20 pounds overweight that's not that
much it's actually a lot but modern
women think it's not a lot but yeah you
would have been considered like 20
pounds would have been considered crazy
50 years ago but so we live in this
delusion but what if some people are
like
like they go to the gym and they like
they build muscle muscle and they should
eat less no but I could you know like we
weigh more if we have muscle and we like
we're talking about overweight we're not
talking about yeah but you could be BMI
overweight yeah that's not factual no no
but that's what they say like if if you
if you go to the gym that's not true
because I I ever since I got back in the
gym I've actually weighed less but not
everyone well I look bigger
but those are exceptions muscle doesn't
weigh as much as fat yeah but what if
you are you kind of it's literally
science
no they this is propaganda yeah actually
it doesn't have to do is look up okay
um we're gonna we're gonna go through
this because I really
um you guys do the metric scale is that
here yeah
all right so do you guys do centimeters
yeah yeah all right so okay wait I'm
trying to pull this up so centimeters
and this is the thing Kevin because a
lot of we live in delusion because the
men accept it from us because we're so
bad
but like um it doesn't make it like not
reality but yeah so um it looks like
um if you're for if you're five three
160 centimeters as a chick a healthy BMI
is
I think you have to be it looks like
under 70 kgs does that sound right how
much is that important only no pounds
um 70 kg I'm trying to see wait wait
five seven 100
that's doable issue the green the normal
way is green so five seven is
yeah one you have to be under 150. yeah
to be in shape so 20 pounds overweight I
think honestly I think 20 pounds brings
you down
depends on how you carry it but I'm
gonna say one maybe two that's my gut
one do you what do you guys think who
thinks it brings you down to a b
probably yeah B yeah all right yeah what
will you be we could do B okay we can do
B
all right 40 pounds
where does that bring you to a c or a d
C
hmm
just gonna go in 20s
see it's like funny are you guys
uncomfortable I feel so uncomfortable
right I don't want to talk about it I
just think it's I hate it but we could
do this men and it would be so easy
we just degrade in men as well why is
that any better just because I just
don't like body shaming anyway it
doesn't mean you need to degrade them
score them on a board okay
shame bad choices no I think it's rude
for you to sit and put things on
everything should we shame already what
you wrote should we shame man from being
criminals you're not writing that on the
ball though are you that's the thing
you've already put b as a kid yeah when
you get married to someone so the minute
you have a kid with someone you're
married to now you're a d are you are
you trying to misunderstand or are you
dumb no it's just rude what's you're
telling me you're not degrees in women
you've literally got grades on a board
the gray dinner
let's live in reality
um we're talking about a kid bringing it
into a marriage not one that you create
all right so we got 20 40 pounds a kid a
hundred pounds would be e obviously I
think that would be a you'd well yeah
but that's also a grading system here
but yes unmarkable
yeah and not every man's even going to
agree with what you're writing on the
board because everyone's got a
preference I'm gonna have a scum we're
gonna ask I'm gonna come in again
they're gonna come in that's the whole
world in this room
well I mean no it's not this well many
why are you sure because it's horrible
you're literally degrading women on a
board what what's nice about that what's
this gonna do for anyone what is the
degree make them make better choices
hold them accountable so they make
better choices people show them their
actions have consequences because if
you're going to someone on your level
like that you're all preaching all
[__] podcasts they're not gonna
matter about this song I have a question
is it better that the world tells them
through their through the outcome
because if you're settling for people on
your level they're not going to start
grading you on a board all that they
don't think they're prestigious don't do
it mentally they won't do it on the
board you can whine about it all you're
not wine and it's rude it's actually
rude it's reality no but it's funny
because
you're on a relationship podcast like
with this one doesn't mean you need to
degrade what I'm saying like what else
would we be talking about not putting
minutes to grades you can say bring them
down and what your preference is you
don't need to start grading women
because all the women watching this and
now thinking what grade am I because
we've tried to have the conversation
we've had conversations about this
doesn't mean it's a great people can I
make my point we've tried to have a
conversation and you still didn't get
the point this is called a visual
exercise this is not gonna make me
understand your point degrading women
then that just means that you're you
know you're all just against like fear
is horrible it's horrible to be a part
of I'm not gonna lie I'm just gonna be
real what you're doing right now you're
just trying to be emotional to derail
the conversation if you're emotional
because you're degrading women if you
don't want to be part of it you can get
up and leave you don't have to like no I
said I wouldn't you asked no one is
forcing you to sit here but no but you
asked for my opinion did you not yes and
then you could say you don't have
anything to say but if you don't if you
and I did then I would still ask my
opinion but you're still trying to
derail the conversation you can just say
well I'm not gonna I'm not the only one
who said it's horrible so yeah that's
right but you keep trying to you keep
trying to do my point is you keep trying
to derail yeah why don't you just go if
you don't like it just go
all right
um so next we're gonna do
what is it what were we gonna do it was
kids
all right how if a girl isn't submissive
how much does that bring her down
probably to like a d
a d
yeah like that that attitude how much
like I'm just wondering d d d she's
starting to get it what do you guys
think Matt I think it's a c because it's
an average of I mean based on man
preference
this is all through preference so it's
like we can think that but some guys
want to think we're gonna ask the guys
what they think in a second so we're
just we're just trying to make it simple
who thinks see you raise your hand a bad
attitude brings you down to a scene
where your skin goes yeah girls girls
raise your hand I I'm I'm actually gonna
say like a c because apparently if
you're hot it's fine
it's not what we said I don't I don't
know if you're listening but it's all
right I said occasionally not by and
large but they get divorced later anyway
because they just make their husband's
life miserable and then they get yes so
I'm gonna pick C all right see what do
you think C or D A D D
see see if I compare her attitude to
this board I would say e to be very
honest
I like you all right we're gonna go down
to
just I think it's like an average if you
picked an yeah this is an F actually I
got rid of the E crazy
um all right bad
attitude
all right no no domestic skills where
does that bring her down to
um I'm gonna say it could be yummy too
she can learn that's what I don't know
for like this that's a big thing for
someone I could be wrong I'd say like
again a CD CD okay if you can't cook or
do or look after or something or some
those kind of domestic things good point
what do you think
um yeah I agree see yeah okay what do
you think can you define it
cooking cleaning looking after a home
domestic skills like are you neat are
you tidy can you come on then you're
definitely in the e that's like yeah
change all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think that's an average of a c right
would you yeah okay oh that's been way
too nice that's way too nice it's way
too nice they're not gonna agree with us
pal yeah but that's what Eula says we're
gonna get our chances running it yeah
we'll see I think we're gonna we're
gonna do for men after yeah yeah we're
gonna write them in but it's going to be
a lot quicker because I think you guys
are gonna say we'll all be brutal let me
get it is there anything else we gotta
do we forget anything that we need to
that subtracts from women guys like that
would like don't tell me where you would
put it just if you think what about
career
[Music]
social media
yeah that's that's a big thing for some
guys okay we're gonna put I'm just gonna
we all say sex work is enough right yeah
please thank you I didn't think anything
I might have got pushed back 10 minutes
ago
but
um
sex work
what did you someone else someone else
said something uh what about a
two-parent household I mean oh yeah
single mother home where does that
grew up and it's incredible I mean don't
don't don't don't tell me they may get
educated I'd say like I'd still say like
a b or a c because then a mother will
really teach you
you say BC what do you say like a b c
we'll see let's say C C C or D because
they would carry like trauma issues
uh I'm stuck between a c and a D I would
only say C if they learn from the
mistake if they haven't then it's a d
we're gonna I think we've had more seats
[Music]
okay I think this is fairly oh and she's
cheated before yeah also not loyal yeah
okay so if she's cheated before that's
enough
yes okay anyone say d f f
okay
all right
um all right guys it's your turn
um all right so
first let's talk about what is your a
give me like what is your a woman fit
feminine friendly
yeah don't look at the list do
you yeah
[Laughter]
that's what we've said during this yeah
um is there anything you disagree with
on the A-list were there women hot
enough to be an a that we showed you
guys yeah of course yeah yeah uh I I
think a big one for a is respectful
that's huge
yeah loyalty it's a it's a massive one
relationship with her father yeah that
is absolutely foundational
does she have to love her mom I was
gonna say that oh yeah
because the way they talk today hold on
the whole kind of relationship with
parents thing what if you don't it's
kind of like I think I don't think
that's like just their background
because it's because if she is still a a
woman in herself regardless of her
parents then she's an a woman I don't
think that should bring no I mean
when it comes to parents it's about Role
Models ideally it's does she have a
strong masculine father figure that she
sees and understands from a young age
so I just want to establish are we
talking about she has a strong male role
model I mean yeah we could we could say
that more specifically but in the vast
majority of cases it would be a father
okay yeah it's kind of like you know a
guy with a criminal record you know
could have overcome it yeah but he's
he's a criminal because of the decisions
he's made as opposed to like that okay
masculinity like a guy with no dad in
the home is probably going to be kind of
feminine yeah yeah and so he probably
won't get an A in masculine he could
overcome it right that doesn't mean for
sure I think that's one thing I'm like
I'm on the first I think my parents is
important oh it's absolutely when I say
not important what I mean is I don't
think if if you just met a girl and you
were like you found out she didn't have
a good relationship with her dad right
and you immediately Mark her down just
purely on that but but
the thing is telltale signs will begin
to show up in most cases those telltale
signs aren't there generalizing those
aren't there because if they're not then
I understand obviously there are
exceptions but by and large because
there are plenty of because we know that
there are plenty of boys who come up in
single parent households and they're
very masculine they just don't control
it
but it's the same yeah but but they
don't control it because they don't
control their emotions I know but we
would we would say that a man has to be
A1 to have mass he would have to have
masculinity to be A1 yeah but part of
masculinity is controlling your emotions
so if he is no no I didn't say emotions
I said controlling his masculinity but
you said here he will end up doing
criminal activity because he can't
control his masculinity but that's
really him not being able to control
your emotions so would you say so would
you say a lot of guys because we would
say like a lot of drug dealers or people
like the road man life would you say
they're not masculine well they can't
control their emotions which is a
feminine truth no I know but I'm asking
no I'm not saying that I'm asking would
you say that they're not masculine
they're masculine in the sense that
they're capable of showing violence but
they're not masculine in the sense that
they're not capable of controlling their
emotions and therefore actions saying
they are not masculine yeah because just
because you you
the fact that they can't show violence
has nothing to do with masculinity it's
just but I didn't I'm not the one that
I'm no is their genetic makeup they have
the ability to shoot sure but I'm not
I'm not the one I wasn't the one that
hits that sat here and said that because
they show violence that makes the
masculine yeah I'm just saying but what
I'm saying is I would say that a lot of
rude men are not as masculine as they
claim to be wow I think I think what I'm
trying to say is we would label
masculinity as an A1 characteristic
right and what I'm trying to say is how
you use that we could talk about stosis
and that's a different conversation but
like a lot of quote-unquote roadmen
right they are very masculine because
they dominate the violent that they're
in they're the alpha in their
environment right they're definitely
more masculine than the private school
kids I went to right because I came from
that kind of ilk but it's how they use
it right which is a different
conversation they're using it in
feminine ways I guess but yeah I don't
think that's masculine I think what
conflicting the issue because what they
are doing is they have the capacity for
violence and that's what they used to
dominate their environment not because
they are masculine that's
can I have an example of a chick that
you think of immediately when you hear
an a uh what's LeBron James's wife yeah
[Laughter]
what is she now you she's still Megan
Good
but is she uh like well how how far does
20 pounds
do you agree with this I would say a lot
lower down like health is wealth
literally how much foundations
[Music]
who says it brings
all right all right so there's one who
what out of the guys who says it brings
you down to a c I'll say a c yeah
okay
uh who says d
okay are you guys not gonna raise your
hands
hey also you guys
you're still in a okay okay sorry so kit
says there's no difference not no
difference I just don't think it's
qualified for a change category okay
good I really like that so that's good
all right all right
oh my gosh guys listen who says a raise
your hand
okay he says V raise your hand
okay who says C raise your hand 20
pounds all right so the majority said c
what [__]
I'm scared of you guys
are good because we see how men think
you know what it is I think I think it's
terrifying no but it's true I think it's
because especially if you're a dude and
you've put in the work to get fit the
absolute last thing you want is someone
who doesn't prioritize Health his health
is the foundation of Worlds hold on but
I think it's the thing is
yeah
this is the thing if you'd listen and
make a change maybe it would be a better
benefits
we're talking about we're not talking
about oh she's slim now she's over with
about 20 pounds bro like she's not she's
not she's not changing categories
actually put that on yeah I hear that I
hear that but also a c is a pass you
know in the woman's nature because the
moment you let that 20 pounds slide then
she's going to move to 14. obviously
yeah
this isn't to argue over all I want is
hands okay this isn't this isn't what
you like is what you like so all right
40 pounds so another 20. that'll bring
you down so is is does it bring you down
to a f then could you chew a 40 pound
weight loss King
I know that's going to be a lot
I know
wait well but what if you talk
no no guys ladies ladies this isn't for
us to give our opinions yeah you see
just ask the men yeah you see that's
that's two that's 40. that's 40 pounds
so imagine she goes from the right to
the left
all right so is she a d now or not
probably a demon okay I would say a d
that definitely takes you down agreed
all right
I'd say
okay well I think the majority right all
right raise your hand d
is your hand D does anyone say f
no okay does anyone say c
okay kids by himself yeah all right just
be honest
okay so next so I'm just gonna assume 60
is an F right yeah yeah
all right all right okay now domestic
skills she's an A but she has no
domestic skills what is she
so raise of hands is a b raise your hand
it doesn't have any domestic skills no
zero but she's still got the good
attitude you can teach her you know okay
no see that's not fair because that's
not what we were talking about what did
we know all right in domestic skills not
if she's nice or if she's got a nice
attitude everything else that's on the
list but she she can't come be if she's
open to learn b b okay
the women to stop whining stop whining
about the men's preferences these are
the men's preferences
nope they didn't whine when we picked
this out so wait where's eating this is
the okay but let's see something like
most most people like know how to take
care of themselves like I have my place
so I look after my own place so she's
moving in and she doesn't know how to
look after it it's calm I'm doing it
anyways
being a housewife but I was learned
right when when in the household I was
growing up me and my siblings were
responsible for taking care of the house
right because the teachers discipline
all of that that's just how I am so if
she if if she has everything else but
that's the only thing she doesn't bring
that's calm but the thing is
and you ask her to learn how to cook
should cook exactly yeah if she's if
she's submissive adding all this stuff
always said is that she doesn't have any
domestic
if she doesn't have domestic then this
this that's different no no what I'm
agreeing with you I'm saying oh if she
if she doesn't know how to cook and she
doesn't have domestic skills but she's
submissive and all of that yeah okay
well yeah there you go okay so next
um all right she
hey but she's got a kid
all right so we're gonna raise of hands
we're gonna raise of hands who says this
one is controversial who says it'd be
okay now who says the C
oh damn now who says a d
okay one D who says an F
uh
this is scary
ladies watching this is what happens if
you become a single mother if you're
gonna leave your home the grass is not
greener on the other side you will go
from an A to an F
no guy who doesn't have a kid wants to
choose a woman to marry have kids with
you exactly like it got we just it's
it's such a major thing for us I don't
know why and it's harsh but it's true
practically it's just all the
responsibility without the authority
it's like if things go wrong it's your
fault but you have no control over this
situation okay that's a scapegoat okay
next I'm gonna ask you a question
all right I want a bad attitude so a
woman has is an A but she's got a bad
attitude is she a b raise your hand
C raise your hand
right she says he says D raise your hand
F raise your hand
okay this is this is the the most common
answer I'm not going to disagree with
you yeah so so guys I mean this is a
lesson for the chicks you can look hot
you can be amazing you can look great I
just want to say if you got a bad
attitude you go from an A to an F I'm
guessing most of the madness from a
Nigerian respect is very important in
our culture
[Music]
she's got all this right but she's
cheated before Oh no
yes
we're gonna wait let me just let me just
rank it okay is she a b
C
d
she cheated once all right he says D
all right
all right again important lesson oh we
forgot body count
ladies we're gonna ask the ladies first
and then we're gonna ask the guy so
ladies you're back in the game
a bee has slept with how many people
let's let's break down actual numbers
all right three to five is a b
all right raise your hand ladies if you
think three to five is a b it's just
like I would say that's fine three to
five yes in modern times historically
it's all [__] but you know
all right I just don't like that all
right
yeah but you're gonna be you're gonna
you're gonna get it guys
all right ten ten bodies brings you down
to a what a c what's that ten ten bodies
is that a c raise your hand women I
would say d d is ten I would say d okay
ten is a d
okay all right how many is an F-15
yeah 15 who's and above all right we're
gonna go 20 so I need above you should
say 15 all right what's Your Number 15
15. what's your 15 what's your number
[Music]
we'll do 20 because I think averaging
that out would be like we're just gonna
for shits and giggles okay men all right
man let's go body count let's break it
down
what is an a guys how many bodies does
she get to still be in realistic before
can I just ask you is it now or yeah
you if you need to give out a report
card okay okay
I'm asking your opinion it should be
what they ideally want right now I'm
asking what the men I'm asking what we
want to know what I really want all
right who says only a virgin gets an a
yeah
all the guys
um all right let's I'm gonna I want you
to raise your hand when it becomes a b
okay one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight nine oh wow okay I need you
to keep it up we're gonna keep it up
okay we're gonna try it again so so
raise your hand guys when it becomes a b
so we start at zero one two
three
four five six seven eight nine okay okay
I would say the average most people said
three or four I think okay so we're kind
of three to five was the women's yeah
yeah okay so we we kind of match so now
we're gonna I want you to raise your
hand when it becomes a c now all right
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven okay okay so
ish
is a c okay now we're gonna go see what
a d is ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen okay so like
there's a lot 10 to 15 roughly we're
just gonna go is a d now the now let's
go to F all right sixteen seven okay
so now this is important for us ladies
to know what percent of women are
getting F's right now I don't know
nowadays and you know men might not tell
us this to our face but this is how guys
think
and this is what I mean when I say the
majority of women are getting F's are
getting D's we don't really have a plus
women anymore oh I forgot one
all right ladies how what does an
abortion bring you down too listen now
okay okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna go down from a to F and I want you
guys raise your hand when you think an
abortion so one abortion who says b
who says C
who says d
who says ath I would say an abortion you
guys didn't even raise your hand no I'm
just not really oh it's okay it's all
right all right what do you well I kind
of I just started messing with that at
all
well the men do so okay you don't have
to vote it's fine yeah it's really hard
like it's a hard topic I say F you say
that's such a weird I say yeah
see maybe see okay yeah I don't know
what do you say
um
part of them and tally I would say F to
be honest okay so that averages out at
like a d so
all right men
one abortion it brings you down all
right so
you're still an a
you're everything cows yeah so just
raise your hand when you think it's one
abortion where she's at okay so a b
C
d
f
wow this was a mix yeah oh wow what
would you guys say the average of that
one I think I feel like C was average
everything yeah I'd say all right so one
abortion would that mean two abortions
brings you down another yeah yeah
because like one is a mistake yeah two
is just like negligence no negligence
is it one negligence what is the thing
we're looking at it as as if the
abortion is separate from the woman once
a woman gets an abortion that damages
something in her yeah and we're talking
about that I'm not well versed I don't
know no think about it because they
always make abortion seem as if it's
this thing where it saves the woman and
this and that yeah we get it women go
through things and they might have they
might think they want to get an abortion
but people never talk about the effects
abortions have on women so if we're
talking about women it doesn't make you
less valuable it's not about being
valuable what I'm talking about if I'm
talking about the woman I want to pick
to be my wife who I want to have a
family with and she's had an abortion
there is a trauma that comes with that
that she's going to pass on to my to my
kit can I can I ask the question what to
you women a woman be would you rather
take the woman who had an abortion
because she doesn't want to have
children out of red luck or the woman
who chose to not have an abortion but
now she's a single mother which one's
more viable in your eyes I'll pick it
neither no but if you had if you had to
choose
like to choose yeah
hold on but I'm giving hold on I'm
giving you I wouldn't pick a woman so
you choose a single mother all right so
you you would rather choose a single
mother yeah right over a woman who's had
an abroad
I understand the importance of human
life exactly yeah and she could have
bought your kid I just think you're
gonna abort mine as well I'd rather to
take the single mom over a chick who's
had an abortion she kill her kid what's
she gonna do to you exactly I just think
she's gonna abort your kid the one thing
we're supposed to do love our kids well
I think
one more thing I thought of one more
thing
STDs a woman that has had an STD before
but we get that where people get that
from from there's both parties it's not
just yeah but I know but yeah you're to
the new party and he's picking like this
is how men think all right ladies first
you think she's had an STD before is she
now uh B raise your hand C raise your
hand
D raise your hand no we got it we gotta
F raise your hand
all right so the the guys aren't yeah I
don't know I would say B all right you
would say B you would say F you would
say F what would you say do you have an
answer MB all right b b
yeah it's terrible she's cute no she's
she's fine actually wait can we Define
this you've got STD you know what we're
gonna do we're gonna do yeah I just I'll
say s t i is a b
all right
the last STD she's had before who says b
I'll say B all right who says c b
you would say b b you would say what
will you two say b c what'd you say f f
all right this averages that line should
I want to see because you two said B I
don't know what we'll do STD here
curable all right non-curable STD or STI
either or
would you guys agree okay okay now to
the men non-curable STD is she uh B
raise your hand C no non-curables none
Cube oh anyone anyone say anything other
than enough nope okay all right curable
she's had an STD before but it's curable
is she a b yeah
all right he says b is she a c
is she a d
okay is she an F
ooh okay what would you guys say the
average that's like a d average I'd say
all right again this is how men think so
if you want to rate yourself ladies this
is what we can look at we can look at
what the men said [__] with more than
five people you're at least a c
um if you have or 20 pounds overweight
you're at least the C if you've slept
with over 10 to 15 people or had an STD
and now you can know that when we say
we're settling for a man we're not
really we're actually lucky to get one
thank you everybody
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait so many friends to do the men in
there yeah we can do that
it'll be more enthusiastic as well to do
the men yeah
it's time for Revenge
all right let's go ladies
Men first men first all right
um no can we do the women first only
only because women always switch their
answers for the like whatever yeah
okay all right so he makes 40
dollars
you raise your hand is he a b raise your
hand is he a c raise your hand c c I'd
say C oh wait this is she tried to hide
it okay
okay uh wait 45 000 pounds sorry this is
see yes okay
you talk crazy
oh I know I know I'll be delusion but
just wait all right so all right guys
I think all right so it's like a teacher
all right he's he's five he's five um
no let's say he's six foot is he a a
raise your hand up what I don't really
care about no no we're we're waiting
here okay assistant raise your hand if
you think he's an a raise your hand if
you think he's a b sorry sorry again all
right all right he's six foot tall okay
is he an A A A yeah
all right so he's fine all right so he's
six foot all right when does he become a
b at five ten is he a b yeah oh really
okay
all right when does he become a c I have
nine five nine yeah
Okay ladies
what do you think is a d five eight five
seven I would say five seven yeah
five five come on
I don't think I've met a guy that's five
five you just don't see them honey
so you're right that's right you're
right
so what is in what is an F let me see a
five for your son no five oh like five
five four if you're shorter than me
I think she's being more accurate though
to be fair I feel like it would be like
every inch would bring you down yeah
because I'm five four I can't be with
someone five two I wouldn't even no you
got it I wouldn't even look at you okay
um all right so sorry honesty right
there income what is it what is a b all
right so this is in pounds so 55 000
pounds
65 000 pounds
75 000 pounds is a b yeah around 75.
okay okay
I would say 100K is a b
because we're gonna have to go into the
millions and I say hey you know you have
to be more realistic yeah if you need a
number I would say eight I would say
eight seventy eighty-five
[Music]
okay
all right so all right so you said 100K
but they all said 75 so we're gonna
stick stuff even overall all right what
is an a how much 500
000 500k is an a oh no no it's okay okay
I would say like
you say half a mill what do you say I
would say 100K 100 okay I'd say six
figures as well 100
100K is hey 100K even that much no I
mean six figures a year six figures is a
million yeah a year that's not that much
okay what's what's not what's a loss
okay so to you a million a year isn't a
okay to be more reasonable yeah to be
more reasonable
everyone
like 400. yeah because I feel like we're
gonna do half a million we are half a
million
[Laughter]
um
you can't tell the difference in terms
of like what they're spending on
realistically a guy who's got half a
meal and a meal realistically you won't
be able to tell the difference oh my God
it is getting hot in here
I need them
okay so all right so we got height all
right let's talk about how good he is in
bed now we should all be virgins so we
shouldn't know the difference yeah we
don't know anything yeah we just yeah
we don't know if a guy is just is let's
say a guy is really good in bed that
brings him to an a an a now if he's bad
in bed what does that bring him down to
F F what do you say if he's bad in bed
what does it bring him down to no I
don't care don't care no okay so you say
I'm in love still an A so
no no but if he's if you have sex with
him and it's it's bad all right it's not
okay it's bad okay
how fall down does he go
see
I'll see all right so you say you said f
let's stop changing no no see because I
have to think okay I have to think
critically here I mean like all right
she says what do you think someone lost
five foot five normally would be bad in
bed so I'll pull out the
[Laughter]
all right so I think the average is the
same
sad facts
okay because you guys are the monster
um experienced we're just the virgins
all right we gotta put good sex up here
that's why I said a because we don't
know we just don't know we don't know
anything
delusion though
okay does body count on a guy matter if
he's a virgin does that bring him up or
down hmm
it's a hard one oh no be honest I don't
think I've ever slept I don't know all
right let's let's be honest okay so he's
a virgin he goes from a name
let's say maybe see okay two down c c c
c yeah whatever they say
a big deal bring it in half a million
yeah they're all good that's what that's
why I said just save money and build it
yeah that's fine
um
what else do we need in here okay looks
can we can can you give me some pictures
if you can fight
oh okay
all right
he's an A but he can't fight what is he
oh my God
you protect me
your best sausage
I wanna I wanna understand you guys's
logic so he's six foot makes 500k he's
great in bed but he can't fight so now
he's a d no he's a b he's a c I would
say c yeah he just needs to get in the
gym and practice some moves be okay so
you say one you say two points what do
you say
um d d okay so the average is a c I
would say
hold on what it's like you have to put
someone breaks into the house like I
need you to do it
that's actually quite scary Indigo
that's terrifying
if he has feminine traits that's fine
you can still have feminine f
I quite FM
all right so he's six what do you define
as feminine listen guys he's he's six
foot makes 500k a year great sex but his
feminine traits what is he what are the
traits though like maybe he cares about
his feelings I don't mind that you
crying I want you to cry okay he paints
these nails all right guys whoa what's
going on who says b who says b no so I
thought they should be um should it be a
bad not balanced but they should I need
you to listen I need you to listen and
raise your hand okay who says Be
who says see
who says D let's say who says F okay so
did you just not vote I did I said B
both see your hands
all right yeah so feminine
oh well that kind of goes into
femininity right yeah but I guess I
guess a rough family background he's an
a with a rough family background I have
a good one he has a criminal record
[Laughter]
[Music]
everybody is a criminal record F yeah
straight I mean what kind of criminal
what is he doing for it is it Financial
is it
drugs
f f no I don't have time for that he's
like a star
[Laughter]
many of you they're in a drug dealer
yeah
absolutely
done it I didn't know until you said
there's an F yeah she did it in an F no
I said like I didn't know about it until
I found out that's fair enough no oh it
was a long story but now looking back he
was enough yeah 100 he was an F in all
aspects that's why you get meant to make
your decisions
take away the boat
I'm looking at the chat guys if you have
anything feel free to Super Chat it I'm
trying to think there's one I had but I
can't remember what it was I want to
understand these things
can you get me some pictures of some
guys
yeah I'd say probably yeah okay Michael
how does someone get tired of 500k
without a mission that's what I want to
understand it's hot without coming to
work yeah
well I mean it's possible
there's a lot of millionaires I grew up
around millionaires none of them had a
criminal record it could be something so
small in fact we're going to burst Obama
in a minute please yeah I'm actually
dying to golf
that's a good picture
[Music]
all right all right can can you can you
put up like some some average looking
guys just some normal like I just want
to get I want us to like I just put put
it off the screen for a second and then
we'll come back can you just pull up
some guys why will from in between cut
that yeah
I'm trying to think who's like average
looking like
um okay if he's overweight if he's 20
all right if he's 20 pounds overweight
he's an A but he's 20 pounds overweight
what does that make him yeah I would say
about the c b
all right so who says b raise your hand
no say B okay all right so
all right 40 pounds is it is it every 20
pounds is is each so C Is 40 pounds I
guess yes okay yeah reasonable yeah
let's see okay all right he's he has all
these stuff but he's boring
okay so he doesn't go out you're not
you're not going any tree you're just he
he's
six foot he's good in bed he's hot but
he's just bored you're never going
anywhere no trips you're just happy I
value okay memories
ladies ladies okay so who says he's now
a b
that's a female to change that isn't it
okay who says he's a c I would say B
yeah because you can just fix the stuff
and make him go in it
okay who says D no
it was would you say that it's most CD
yeah so let me get this straight a guy
that looks like Michael B Jordan is six
foot 500k in good sex it's a c because
he's boring yeah yeah this is why we die
alone ladies
because it's all about the memories the
stuff that you do yeah
oh my God
how do you guys think these men get to
500k
by being boring
guys
okay all right all of this but he's
awkward
oh no I don't do well with Oakwood okay
all right so so raise your hand if you
say B oh when you say okay not social
yeah not like you can't really it's just
he's not social skills he doesn't know
how to talk to the ladies like he's not
a flirt I'm not amazing
and he's just kind of awkward and boring
and Converse like a nerd you know what I
mean like
social skills are dead Okay Okay so
raise your hand if you say c c okay
we're gonna go with that you're gonna
say yeah
um
okay let's do dress sense so I'm all
right so this guy
all right all right we're gonna call
this guy glasses guy what is he his name
is
six foot he makes 500 000 a year he's
actually quite cute and um he has great
sex with you
um but that's what he looks like I want
you to raise your hand if you'd go on a
date
yeah yeah I would okay I want to raise
your hand if you'd marry him just off
these numbers
okay if he takes care of me loves me why
would you loyal to me okay but what does
he go down to is he um looks wise all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna write is he a
b
c c
okay so glasses guy can you show him the
next one king
can we talk about loyalty
all right he's an A but he's a cheater
all right so is he a b raise your hand a
c raise your hand
a d raise your hand
and F raise your hand this is the
biggest cat because every [__] has an
ex-boyfriend that cheated on her yeah
but I didn't have
like yeah but it's like if we didn't
like him we wouldn't pick him in the
first place you don't you don't
accidentally [__] the ugly guy with no
social skills
yeah of course so is The Quiet Ones
okay you got another guy King
all right this guy
is
yeah we just we just look up random guy
imagine
he's watching this podcast
is he a c oh Lord
please please pay attention class is he
is he a b is he a c do you know I'll say
F because of his teeth like it just
resembles all right all right okay you
know what I think money can do a lot of
things so I would do D yeah
because he can go to Turkey and get the
veneers and he can definitely work on
himself he can get a bit of bugs now
let's go to the men
let's go let's go out of delusion
well why because the men's what they men
ask for is perfectly reasonable you guys
is like any because any woman we didn't
do dress sense oh okay we'll do it looks
you said looks yeah it looks fine look
it because any woman pretty much outside
of the hotness stuff could be an A or at
least a b but not every guy can we add
one thing driving do they drive I think
that's a big thing
quick yeah if he he all of this but he
can't drive is he a b is he a c why why
he's driving can we please please please
Dance please raise the hand all right d
and f yeah
all right d d she doesn't care what do
you say I've never had someone to try
try such as
I don't know
four months I know okay all right man
how much for Renee what do you think so
you're picking out a man for your sister
yeah
a b
money yeah yeah yeah
1875 yeah and um just so you know people
that make 100K in the UK I think it's
about two percent yes just so you know
so wouldn't that be too high because the
ten percent yeah no it's your a
I'd say like
yeah
I would say personally I would say 80k
for a because with 80k you can leave a
very perfect life and have a family I
mean TK is a pilot by the way
yeah
I think six figures 80 to 100 yeah
okay what's a c
C actually that's mad because that's
actually like higher than the average
the average is like 30 yeah the average
is like 30 or maybe yeah maybe 40 to 50.
see I would say 40 to 50. yeah yeah okay
yeah that's fair
I'm pretty sure the average is 35 K yeah
isn't it yeah that's all right d
okay
all right all right all right guys what
who do you think of when you think of a
c an average looking guy
probably will
no I think will I think Will's less than
average
you think so yeah
I'd say someone like Daniel Radcliffe
Harry Potter okay
average no I wouldn't you say he's
better than will
I'd say wheel is like the out I'd say
Wheels like a bank I think I think
Will's like that lower than average it's
Cod yeah
fair enough
you'll see him about
um
how much should how much should bad sex
bring a guy down
if I'm choosing for my daughter
shouldn't at all yeah
it's not a priority nah shouldn't be at
least all right
um if he can't fight how much should
that bring a guy down oh that's a lot
that's bringing you down a lot first one
is protect yeah you gotta and provide
you know if you can't protect well is he
is he still making good money
because the real the real is like the
more money you make the less physical
education you're getting into yeah
lower economic standing that's fact you
get into physical surgery so if he's
making the money it's not that important
you're making the money someone can
still rub your hands
but if you have enough money do you
think you're more likely to be robbed in
a rough area or a potion can you hear
him well I mean in terms of likelihood
[Laughter]
I think you're more likely to get like
to get mugged or robbed in Brixton than
you are in Chelsea yeah 100 but like you
need to be able to fight
[Music]
if it comes down to it let's say you're
on the street you can't just give him
money but also as well being real like
the person who's in who is up there
right yeah like if there's like three
four goons it doesn't matter how good
you can fight like you're getting [__]
yeah but yeah we're talking about and
and if you and if you're up there you
don't have other people who can fight
like you have no internet
it's not just about fighting you might
not win there's a lot that comes that a
man gets as a man when he knows how to
fight yeah I agree I'm I think you learn
it from a young age as well I'm not
saying it's not important I just think
the the wealthier you are the less less
of it is yeah but we're voting based
solely on capability to fight sometimes
who says Be
who says C oh so C okay see no matter
more of it oh if we forgot to do age for
the ladies oh yeah oh yeah
um ladies age so he's the same age is
that an a
now is that is that b oh sorry repeat
that he's the same age as you oh yeah I
don't care you don't care it doesn't
matter okay if he's younger than you no
no no that was quick all right all right
it's like one year five years what does
that make him
no oh no no that's like d yeah that's
enough for me yeah it's an F
just like okay old it's a day for me all
right all right 10 years older
25 I would go down to B yeah
okay so 25 it starts we just got to stay
alive 25 feet 60 year old
um age gap for your daughter
three to eight years older
um and so is it a negative one it's
older than that no no no when does it
become a negative the age Gap I think I
think 15 yeah
all right so at 15 years is it a b
for 15 years I'll say it's like uh let's
see I agree yeah because you don't want
someone that's gonna die and leave yeah
yeah or someone who's physically yeah
people they think of this we're like oh
he's Rich yeah the face it's an
incentive for them he's rich and soon
he's gonna die
um okay what other character traits
should women look for in an a
little bit leadership yeah leadership
initiative and pressure I would say it's
a big one so yeah I'll bring back the
the one we we said for the ladies and I
would I'll start with my own rating if
he has a criminal record I don't care
what it is that's an F I agree yeah yeah
of course
wow thank you yeah I agree criminal
record still in the sweetness for my
daughter absolutely no way or not yeah
it doesn't matter if it's Financial or
whatever yeah yeah was he avoiding tax
if you
[Music]
shoot Our Ladies First how much does a
kid drop him or does it at all one kid
one kid it depends if I've got kids
how does that all right all right raise
okay one kid says he's a b raise your
hand
one kid says he's a c raise your hand
okay one kid says he's a d raise your
hand
uh I'm gonna say C I say yes
I would actually say B and I changed my
mind on this and I'll tell you why
because before the way I thought of it
was like that's like that's such a big
commitment but the truth of the matter
is most men don't have custody their
kids so you're really only seeing the
kid a couple days a month so that's why
I would say it's actually not as big of
a deal or the other way around like like
most dads get like every other weekend
that's four days a month yeah yeah
[Music]
though remember
yeah yeah I mean oh yeah oh yeah
that's fine yeah then yeah but if it is
then it is most of the time it's
probably not going to I'll say it okay
so all right who said all right two kids
makes you a what for the guy two
mistakes yeah that's the episode it
could have been an ex-wife why is it a
mistake yeah how old are we how old are
we between 15 years old I would just say
CE again okay okay so um men what do you
guys think about kids for your daughter
or sister
[Music]
I mean
I'd say I'd say bocell
one's like all right one one's a b yes
Two's A C sorry one really the question
is how many baby moms yeah
[Music]
yeah okay so baby mamas makes him uh
he's just gonna do it again yeah
she'll become the third yeah
fat literally all right if he's boring
hey hey
I mean that's good he's not doing the
most boring means peaceful if he's
awkward hey awkward don't give a [__]
because if you're gonna bring around
family gatherings okay
okay so what other traits should women
look for in a husband
physique stoicism is a big one yeah
should women look for in a husband
physique
yeah honesty Jackson
it's just funny you know it's funny this
is the first character trait I've heard
whole night honestly honest
I think a man that can do things around
the house disciplined yeah that covers
all of it what about like a handyman
like a man who can actually do stuff I
think that's very important
all right all right he's he's an A but
he's not handy is he a woman a b
because remember it's still earning the
money yeah
think about the half a meal please
okay
[Music]
oh Lord okay
nice job my brain hurts
wow
you know how easy that was to to
brutalize men so yeah I know what it was
happy about it as well we did the women
one woman three we did the women right
one woman had to leave yeah she was like
I'm out we do the men we're clapping
we're laughing
around the ladies was was seeing how men
rank women surprising to you
don't surprising but it's just like
it's it was surprising what would you
like yourself yeah they don't really
focus on like the kind of [__] I guess
the character not the characteristics
but you know what I mean like women
always go for like personality traits
like oh he can't be boring and like men
are just like nah I don't care as long
as he can take care of my daughter so it
sounds very like yeah well can we can
they right can everyone rank themselves
men and women whoa mind your business
I think everyone should write themselves
oh let's go what what is it oh
all right what about you
girl
unrealistic no no we are being the real
lesson we just we just did the grading
sale you are wait let me get this
straight you guys you guys think you're
as hot as Margot Robbie you are I'm not
an ugly girl okay you're not as hot as
Margo wrong I think that's preferences
though
no thank you so I think I'm starting to
why do women lie to each other
Margot Robbie really
it's a different type like I don't I
don't think that's not the type of woman
I would go for personally yeah okay
um any of the girls that we listed the
one with the most symmetrical face you
really think you're both as hard as her
it's not I don't again it's like that's
just my preference okay okay I actually
have a question
I have a question do you do you think
that you make five hundred thousand
dollars a year I don't okay no I get it
it's the realistic kind of thing but I'm
just saying that I'm not any less than
like I don't think she's better looking
at me like it's just not my preference I
do think that all of the women that we
showed earlier are better looking than
me so I would not give myself a name and
I I think this is delusional
go ahead
um
what do you we can or what do you what
do you rate yourself I'm gonna do that A
B C D at home I'm gonna look at you
no no rating no rating no rating wow
not okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna raise
your hand okay so a are you an a raise
it's only humbling if you're delicious
okay all right what do you think you are
um I would say realistically because of
my weight I would say a b
okay
see how nice that was where she was like
you know what I'm not perfect it's like
it makes you like okay you kind of like
her more okay so what do you what do you
rate yourself
based on that yeah b b okay all right
say b as well actually yeah a b
I will go for B what I'll go fubby
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second
hold on I got it log back in I was
standing so long oh wait are we put in
the polls on it like no they're gonna be
no I'm gonna Read Super chats because I
think we're we're kind of I was gonna
wrap up we I know we've been here it was
really hard to get through the woman
part I'd even did the stuff guys
yourself King
oh CC I see what do you think
Oh I thought the men were gonna rate US
I suggested it
[Laughter]
do you want to rate US no I don't care
yeah
I don't know you okay I don't know how
much you make I don't know
oh okay well then I mean okay
okay yeah what do you think
um well yeah go ahead individually yeah
we're at the guys why not um oh like
everyone here literally everyone
brutalism oh my God okay it's all right
um right well I'll start with you
um I'd say you're a b yeah thank you
yeah
um okay I'll tell you'll be
um I already know you guys I would say
like B
this would be very nice you have to be
nice you're just being nice I would say
see
um I'll say see
what about behind oh sorry sorry I
forgot about you
um
you're quite cool I would say c
what about you
okay
um
I'd say
it
b c b
um
it comes with type as well do I mean
because I'm looking no no it's hard it's
hard to say it publicly no one cares off
of type because I don't know how much
you guys earn off of time I'd say
a
c b b
[Music]
B
C
okay what about you I you don't wanna no
no all right what about you
I'll respect I'm not gonna rate them in
but I would love to hear them I actually
want you to write okay I don't want
YouTube what about you you have to wait
that's cool actually yeah go on you know
I guess both do it yeah
you'll be the most honest as well yeah
don't be a little bit emotional honest
be honest
um
[Music]
you know I think everyone wow
Nature's coming out yeah
I think
I'm an average chick yeah see what do
you write yeah
just rate them all right
um
all right you know
I'd say I'd say all right
you can't look at them
[Laughter]
does this make it easier it's not
someone else's show but I just feel like
this is a perfect I'll tell you what I'm
gonna invite you on to my show and we're
gonna watch this video yeah yeah yeah do
it on yourself
I'm holding that I'm holding it
everyone's witness
everyone's witness what are you doing
Sunday I'll kick off I'm busy okay
[Laughter]
um all right guys who which girls are
willing to be rated
[Music]
give the women a grade out of this one
here yeah yeah no no it's just kind of
now will you but you remember right we
did it all together yeah but we did it
off of looks we didn't really do it off
of because we don't know much about them
okay okay but I'm saying from the guys
what they've what they've gathered from
the women tonight do they seem
submissive did they seem who would get
would any get a proposal from you maybe
out of what we've seen tonight tonight
she's so uncomfortable
no I'm not I'm not too sure well I'm
gonna say B
okay b or a
I have no kids by the way
yeah we have no kids
um see so C
b b o a c interesting I just think
you're the most submissive
what about you
[Music]
all right well that was a lot of fun
that wasn't all good at all yeah
everyone
yeah
because you'll be the most honest
you meet the girls too rate the girls
too there you go it makes you feel
better all right yeah who wants my
rating no one no one asks okay
[Music]
okay all right
um you may be
[Laughter]
strong
um
hey Mike see I think if you lost a
little weight you'd be higher
um
[Music]
C but it's like a height thing I'm
really tall
um
C but it's it's I think if you lost a
little weight you'd again be higher I
think you could actually be a really
strong B but you're just gonna lose like
20. I do go to a gym it's fine yeah it's
probably just eating you probably just
got to eat less
fair enough you know but
you're not that argumentative you know
you're you're young
um
you're you're pretty so I'll give you uh
but you argue a lot you're gonna be sick
she's
she's a strong B I would say
um
strong B you'd almost be an A but you're
26 so it's like ah
sorry not not even guys what yeah um
anyways guys I'm gonna I'm gonna read
the super chats now and then we're gonna
close out the show so think of your
closing thoughts all right puffy Vegas
I'm afraid the girls because no one else
seven seven
puffy Vegas I'm tired of these women
lying women cheat at a higher rate than
men I have never met a woman that was
faithful
um uh if you include kissing Dr David
Baker according to the CDC 2019 for the
number of women's sexual partners you
would have
oh you guys would have a 26 failing
grade with most getting a c according to
2018 by nectar you would give 67 percent
of women a failing grade so 67 percent
of women would fail
um Pearl you need to add age to the list
um The Haven project here's the bottom
line by and large for men I got um Too
Many Bodies is a problem period the
exact number doesn't matter type Grand
Canyon vaginas are not acceptable
um 90 free-toe pie corn Shadow eyes has
convinced me that generalizing is bad I
say not all grapes are bad and neither
are women abusers or pedos
um oh because he's saying we can't
generalize
like that's that's this point it's
ironic okay
um The Haven project here's the bottom
line by and large just potential wives
most women who are of the Boomer Gen X
and Millennial Generations in the US and
UK are a lost cause delusional and 10
below average at best uh due to feminism
The Haven project all these beautiful Is
Not Gold the media said Amber Heard is
beautiful look at how that ended up
Lionheart Richard women want the
authority of men the Privileges of women
the accountability of children and the
responsibilities of infant and the
superiority of God non-stop rev TV these
women won't change your attitude and
behavior circle of friends stop partying
and showing and promoting sexuality on
Instagram that you won't you're only
loyal to your feelings Jonathan for the
22 year old listen to the Princeton mom
my co-author
zero Fallout 80 percent of Western women
are not marriage material lightheart
Richard how to choose a guy you can
submit to date with intent maintain
Chastity and involve your oh I read that
one
um I'm gonna refresh this really quick
guys really quick we're gonna refresh it
okay that's all of them so thank you
guys for coming this was a this is a
great show
I love it when I love it when I have a
show where everyone just has a good
attitude no one's too offended I know we
had but I think did she do porn I think
that was that someone said she had a
porn like in her bio oh really oh yeah
corn I know I forgot the rules
but yeah you know so that's why she was
mad because she was getting an f and
guys you're gonna keep seeing this women
men are men don't tell us these things
to our face but they think it and it's
better we know and the truth of the
matter is a lot of the women that are
whining and crying about ratings are
just mad that they get rated as F's so
if women have a visceral reaction to
this usually it's because they don't
match up and they don't want to improve
so um final thoughts go ahead
um it was a good eye-opener to see like
what to kind of expect from certain guys
and like I feel like again I still got a
lot of learning to do to see how like
how to navigate certain things but yeah
I think I had like a lovely lovely time
in all of you guys and I think it was
nice to talk about like the reality of
how mentality actually works with us you
know men and women so yeah it was great
yeah I would agree well firstly Pearl
thank you for having me back on the show
um it was a really great show
um I would say you know just as women
have a lot of respect for yourself and
never ever compromise on your morals
um and I really stand by that that is um
that is my motto in life and yeah it was
really interesting to hear from all the
men here today
um I feel like I've learned a lot so um
I'm gonna go and debate with my partner
and
yeah he loves you by the way he loves
the show yeah he's he's like listen bro
but I seriously I really appreciate like
you if you get like roasted in the
comments you know you you come back you
don't yell at me like I will say you
know I'm gonna give you a b
you know and I'm telling you that's rare
because a lot of women if the comments
don't take their side come back and just
start yelling at me like it's my fault
to be fair to suitcase
when she came on last time at the end we
were just chatting and stuff and before
she left she came up to she was like so
like how can I be a bear partner to my
man yeah
he's watching me yeah we we like her
here you've got a good run man
I have hundreds
the amount that can handle criticism and
not like cry later and like [__] to me
and like you know I've even had chicks
sue me or threatened to see me I mean it
gets thrown out good luck but it's like
it's just yeah it's craziness I'm
telling you I I really understand the
plight of the modern man because I've
had so many of these shows
so yeah shout out to you very very great
guest thank you
um I like being here and I always have a
great time so oh go ahead thank you for
very much for having me back Pearl it
was a great show and I really
enjoyed to hear uh from both perspective
of women and men how they think and I
learned a lot as well and I've seen how
women think so uh in a bubble we have a
bubble lens whereas men are really
really uh Technical and um yeah like
they see life through the real world
lens so that was uh good
it's enough
um my final thoughts are when it comes
to betting to everybody males and
females just make sure you answer that
question so Source out all the red flags
um
[Laughter]
that's one of them just make sure you
ask the right questions
okay go ahead oh
um thanks for having me
um you know love coming on the show
um I think for me I kind of already said
this but just noticing the difference
that when we were you know kind of
categorizing men we had a really great
time doing it we all had fun and even
the guys were like yeah like you know I
mean we were completely fine kind of
reflecting looking ourselves looking at
how we match up and everything but then
when we did that on the women's side it
became very awkward one when we had to
go and stuff
um and that's not saying that we have to
grade each other all the time but I
think it's just interesting the cultural
space we're in that we are so accepting
and almost even celebrate kind of
holding men to a certain standard
um and when men say look this is what I
like this is what we like
that it's always met with backlash so I
think it's just it's just interesting
and I think if women had this report
card grading scale at 15 a lot of us
would make different choices but we
don't we live in delusion where we don't
know and nobody tells us so that's why I
really think it's important to be honest
right so you know I I hope the younger
chicks see this don't don't come see
stay Haze
okay go ahead are you not going I know I
I always do second row last
um yeah
I'm a regular Watcher anyway so well
yeah good show um basically just going
on from what you're saying it's just it
is weird to see certain things
um and it's quite surprising what women
don't know about men as well like it is
quite surprising and now shut they are
when we say certain things but yeah good
show though good show yeah all I got to
say is uh yeah many thanks pal I would
say for my observations it seems like a
lot of men don't understand women's
short-term mating strategy and a lot of
women don't understand men's long-term
making strategy so I'll say you know you
want to make sure you get that on point
um of course whenever assessing any
human animal remember the only action is
truth and whatever they say is of course
just words and yeah you know I think I
think when it comes to you know gender
Dynamics I think it's important to
remember that we are best together like
we're not trying to separate you know
men and women I don't think men and
women should be a part I think they
should certainly be together and at the
end of the day this is the aim but
certain ideologies bring them apart and
yeah lastly if you want a music session
my studios in East London it's Jay
Johnson official j-y Johnson with an H
on the ground yeah and I really think
that the only we got to stress that the
only way women and men can come together
is if women start learning what men want
and at least trying to be it oh sorry I
just wanted to add something
um so when we're written ourselves I
give myself a c and that's because of
many different factors but in terms of
look I think I'm the best looking money
[Laughter]
um okay let me just double check there's
no super chats guys get your women
shouldn't vote shirts I mean just
watching this show right here do you
really think women should vote you know
I really enjoyed the ladies but we
shouldn't have them in the polls if you
give me one I'll I'll wear it online for
an episode well you can order it in the
link
well um I'll wear them well I I don't I
don't have them here yet they're
pre-orders come back in like a month
we'll have it
um
yeah okay there's another Super chats
yeah we're also guys sign up for the
Google Forum
um if blood if you're watching or
blessing someone make sure that's in the
description we are going to do an event
in London former show guests are invited
so if you've been on the show sign up
for the Google form so you can be
notified or follow me on Instagram just
probably things one
um it may be a live podcast
um and we may actually invite some
musicians that have been on the show to
perform I I haven't figured it out
completely yet I have some ideas yeah
I'm thinking
um I I've been gaslighting you guys I'm
gonna do it eventually I'm thinking
November you know so that's what I'm
thinking so make sure you sign up for
the Google forms you can be notified um
remember we do Pearl daily five days a
week and we have our shows Thursday and
Friday if you want to come on the show
message the pregame show on Instagram or
Romeo
um what's your Instagram
Romeo official
official Romeo 27 you know
um I think that's all the announcements
um sign up for my fourth tier if you
want a one-on-one call with me once a
month
um and I'll teach you all the YouTube
secrets and we are signing talent in the
next month in London we're looking for
two to three more so if you want to
apply pitch me your show tell me what
you're trying to do like the video on
your way out I won't let anyone come
that hasn't liked the video so subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time
oh bye